le 14 septembre dernier dans une tribune
au Monde plus de 300 scientifiques
appelaient la France à soutenir un
traité de non prolifération des énergies
fossiles selon les signataires l'accord
de Paris ne suffit pas en l'état à
atteindre les objectif climatique que
l'humanité s'est donné en 2015 dans une
seconde tribune au Monde paru le 27
octobre dernier plus de 300 patrons et
cadres
dirigeants de tous les secteurs exprimés
le soutien à cette proposition ces
prises de position s'appuyent notamment
sur le constat drressé par l'Agence
internationale de l'énergie qui estimait
en
2021 qu'aucun nouveau projet fossile
n'avait sa place pour atteindre la cible
de neutralité carbone en
2050 ce constat est étaayé par une
enquête d'une d'un consortium de médias
internationaux parus la semaine dernière
cette enquête identifie
422 sites existant ou envisager
d'extraction fossile dans le monde
appelé bombe carbone dont les émissions
potentielles combinées représentait plus
de deux fois le budget carbone à ne pas
dépasser pour maintenir le réchauffement
climatique au niveau national à
1,5° C ces 422 sites combinés
conduiraient également à aller au-delà
du budget carbone à ne pas dépasser pour
respecter la cible de 2° C un/ers de ces
sites ne sont pas euh ne sont qu'à
l'état de projet dont certains d'entre
eux ont la capacité de produire du gaz
ou du pétrole jusqu'au début du 22e
siècle quant au près 300 sites en
exploitation leur potentiel d'émission
excède de 80 % le budget carbone
permettant de maintenir les température
mondiale à 1 de 5 C ces 422 bombes
carbon sont concentrés pour moitié dans
trois pays Chine Russie
États-Unis total énergie arrive en 2e
position des groupes liés à des projets
ou des sites considérés comme des bombes
carbones deux établissements bancaires
figurent dans le top 10 des plus grands
financeurs BNP pariba et Crédit Agricole
dans ce contexte il nous a semblé
particulièrement important de vous
réunir cet après-midi vous réunir d'une
part nous souhaitons donner
l'opportunité à la communauté
scientifique par la voix de Jean housel
de relayer son appel auprès du
gouvernement représenté aujourd'hui par
Man manpierunaché et auprès des
parlementaires que nous sommes d'autre
part nous proposons au gouvernement de
clarifier la position sur le sujet à
quelques semaines de la COP 28 qui se
déroulera à Dubaï je remercie la
ministre de la transition énergétique de
se prêter à l'exercice je m'adresserai
tout d'abord à Monsieur jusel avec une
question directe quelle devrait être la
trajectoire d'évolution de la
consommation et de la production
d'énergie fossile pour respecter et
espérer respecter l'accord de Paris
comme je l'ai dit
lae consid qu'aucun nouveau projet
fossile devrait être autorisé mais il
n'y aura pas également de conséquences à
tirer concernant les sites actuellement
en exploitation comme les skit la
tribune que vous avez Cigné ma deuxè
série d'interrogation est adressée à la
ministre de la transition énergétique
elle porte sur notre capacité capacité à
traduire juridiquement et
opérationnement et opérationnellement la
proposition formulée dans la tribune du
Monde faudrait-il fixer à la faveur de
la COP 28 des objectifs mond
de sortie des énergies fossiles
différencié en fonction des sources
d'énergie différencié également en
fonction des régions du monde enfin et
avant toute chose ces propositions
ont-elles une chance d'aboutir je
rappelle qu'un objectif de réduction
progressif de l'ensemble des énergies
fossiles avait un temps été envisagé
lors de la COP 27 à l'initiative de
l'Inde avec le soutien de l'Union
européenne et des États-Unis mais
n'avait pas été repris dans la décision
au final sous l'influence notamment de
l'Arabie Saoudite et de la Chine voici
quelques questions auxquelles vous
pourrez répondre dans le cadre d'un
propos liminire je ne doute pas que les
membres de notre commission vous
interpelleront ensuite sur la
déclination que déclinaison que devrait
prendre cette trajectoire de sortie des
énergies fossiles dans notre pays
notamment d'un point de vue fiscal et
budgétaire cela tombe bien car notre
assemblée aura dans quelques semaines à
débattre du projet de loi de finances
monsieur Josel je vous cède la parole
merci beaucoup bonjour à tous et à
toutes merci monsieur le Président merci
Madame la Ministre bon c'est c'est vrai
que je vous remercie d'associer la la
communauté scientifique à disons à ce
débat voilà donc et sur effectivement
cette
proposition d'un traité de
nonprolifération des énergies fossiles
qui qui est déjà une proposition assez
ancienne he de certains pays et que nous
engageons effectivement collectivement
notre pays notre gouvernement voilà à
reprendre en tout cas à porter euh donc
par rapport au aux trois questions que
vous avez posé cher président moi je
suis je suis plus effectivement vous
invité plus à à répondre à la finfin
disons dis à dire quelques mots sur le
sur le premier point par rapport à cette
nécessité alors pour nous de don
prifération des énergies fossiles c'est
vrai que je suis plus à l'aise sur le
pourquoi que sur le comment donc Madame
le Ministre vous êtes invité à dire
comment on fait je comprends alors sur
le pourquoi mais ça je je crois que
disons on peut pas être motivé sur le
comence si on ne sait pas pourquoi on
fait ça he c'est c'est ça qui est très
important et que j'aime bien rappeler
quand même disons c'est c'est pas un jeu
he c'est ça que je veux dire tout
simplement c'est quelque chose
d'extrêmement
important qui qui met
effectivement je dirais qui qui pose la
question
de bien de de notre comportement
d'aujourd'hui par rapport à à ce que
sera notre climat dans la deuxième
partie de ce siècle et donc par rapport
au jeunes d'aujourd'hui hein c'est
vraiment une question très profonde je
dis toujours de façon très simple que
l'objectif de l'accord de Paris limité à
bien en deç 2 degrés si possible 1 degr
5 c'est que doit-on faire pour que
finalement pour que les jeunes
d'aujourd'hui puissent s'adapter au
réchauffement climatique sans trop de
difficultés c'est c'est c'est bien ça
notre objectif commun et et et le
problème du du ce qu'on doit faire bien
ce qu'on doit faire c'est aujourd'hui
qu'on doit le faire hein pour
effectivement nous décidons c'est un peu
le message nous décidons je dirais
disons d'ici 2030 largement de du climat
que nous aurons enfin disons que nous
l'aigrerons en tout cas pour moi ou que
vous aurez pour certains au aux jeunes
d'aujourd'hui dans la 2uxiè partie de ce
siècle alors bon simplement quelques
rappels donc alors pourquoi on fait le
lien avec les combustibles fossiles donc
tout simplement parce que le phénomène
auquel nous sommes alors je dirais
confrontés et est quelque chose d'assez
simple disons que nous avons
collectivement par nos activités
augmenté l'effet de serre donc augmenter
la la composition de certains composés
alors le premier gaz à effet de serre
c'est la vapeur d'eau mais nous n'en
modifions pas directement les quantités
dans l'atmosphère par nos activités hein
donc indirectement oui par par exemple
en augmentant la température de l'océan
il y a plus de vapeur d'eau dans dans
l'atmosphère qu'il y a qu'il y a 50 ans
hein c'est observé mais ce n'est pas le
cas pour d'autres composés en
particulier le le disons
le premier composé à effet de serre donc
don sur lequel nous disons souvons
effectivement ce sont les les disons le
CO2 le dioxyde de carbone il y a le
méthan le protoxyde d'azote de façon
assez simple tous les composés à chaque
fois qu'il y a plus de trois plus deux
atomes à partir de trois atomes ça vibre
et c'est à effet de serre c'est de façon
assez simple à part je je dirais à part
l'azote l'oxygène et puis et puis les
gazes rares en fait par exemple l'ozone
où il y a TR trois atomes d'oxygène
c'est un gaz à fait de ça donc on on a
fait ça qu'est-ce qu'on a fait en
faisant ça bien disons il y a 50 % de
plus de de de de gaz carbonique qui a
qui a 200 ans voilà de doublé en méthane
20 % de plus en prottoxyde d'azote on
peut décliner t tous ces chiffres qui
sont bien documentés bien documentés à
toutes les échelles ça va jusqu'à
l'échelle presque parti enfin disons
personnel on peut faire son bilan
carbone l'état fait son bilan carbone la
citpa est une organisation très très
disons qui qui donne des chiffres tout à
fait clairs sur comment on le fait voilà
donc on on sait euh ce qu'on ce qu'on a
fait collectivement bien disons cet
effet de ser c'est simplement ça piège
une partie du rement solaire une fois
qu'il a été réfléchi à la surface de la
planète on augmente l'effet de serre on
augmente le chauffage he grosso modo à
peu près on l'a augmenté de 1 % donc
faut pas être surpris si on augmente le
chauffage que la température augmente
donc même si c'est compliqué dans dans
la boîte atmosphère océan augmenter de 1
%
et disons avec comme conséquence alors
j'aime bien soulligner très br ement que
de 5 % supplémentairire il y a que 1 %
qui reste dans le dans l'atmosphère qui
sont l'essentiel va dans l'océan plus de
90 % vont dans l'océan et c'est quand
même dans l'océan qu'il faut aller voir
le réchauffement la réalité du
réchauffement climatique et elle est
vraiment très claire parce que
l'élévation du niveau de la mer ça en
est un double témoignage c'està-dire
disons c'est à la fois pour à peu près
40 % le le réchauffement de l'océan
l'océan se réchauffe il se dilate et
puis voilà pour pour le reste ou
l'essentiel du reste et bien la Cros je
viens tout juste de ce one Planet polar
semite voilà qu'on a ouvert voilà qui va
durer 3 jours et vraiment il y a un cri
d'alerte sur le le rôle des calottes
futures des calottes glaciaires qu'on
maîtrise mal et leur contribution à
l'élévation du niveau de la mer et
effectivement l'élévation du niveau de
la mer est deux fois plus importante
aujourd'hui 4 mm par an pratiquement que
qu'il y a dans que la deuxième partie du
21e siècle alors ce que ce que
j'aimerais dire c'est que ce qu'on vit
aujourd'hui y compris pour cette disons
ce ce ce doublement du de de l'élévation
du taux d'élévation d'élévation du du
niveau de la mer et bien ce n'est pas
une surprise he c'est ce que notre
communauté envisage depuis une
cinquantaine d'années hein depuis dans
les rapports successifs du jet que ce
soit pour l'élévation du niveau de la
mer que ce soit pour le
rythme disons pour le rythme de de moyen
de de de réchauffement moyen de de
l'atmosphère c'est à peu près entre 2 et
et 3 diè de degrés actuellement et puis
aussi et bien pour euh pour ce qui tout
ce qui concerne les événements extrêmes
disons qui sont finalement une
manifestation parce que quelquefois on
pose la question on parle de
réchauffement climatique oui c'est bien
réchauffement mais sur lequel se
superpose d'une certaine façon un
dérèglement qui se manifeste par des
événements extrêmes plus intense plus
fréquent hein c'est c'est ça la réalité
qu'on vit et voilà je je disons bien sûr
peut-être que ponctuellement il y a des
choses qui vont même plus vite que que
que l'on le pensait mais globalement
vraiment si on regarde les rapports
successtifs du GC nous sommes sur ce qui
était anticipé donc euh voilà donc euh
et ça ça doit nous inciter quand même le
fait que notre communauté a correctement
euh
disons envisager correctement envisager
l'évolution du climat au cours des
dernières enfin depuis depuis une
quarantaine d'années depuis le débuts du
siècle ou même un peu avant depuis le
rapport chararm
79 ça doit nous inviter mais je sais que
vous en être conscience on nous invité à
à disons à accorder de la crédibilité à
cette même communauté par rapport à ce
qu'elle nous dit pour disons les les
décennies qui viennent et l'après 2050
et au-delà hein c'est une invitation
claire voilà il voilà donc je je bien
sûr ça ne veut pas dire qu'il y a pas
d'incertitude hein mais euh voilà alors
que nous dit cette communauté bien que
si on ne fait rien pour aller vers 4 à 5
degrés hein si on continuait à émettre
des gaz à effet de serre sans y porter
attention euh disons en fait il y a CIN
scénarios donc deux scénario émetteur et
c'est un peu ça on fait rien pour lutter
contre le réchauffement climatique euh
ce serait bien de de respecter l'accord
de Paris on y reviendra bien en D de
degrés si possible 1 degr 5 en fait il y
a aussi un intermédiaire sur lequel on
est plutôt actuellement c'est-à-dire
qu'on va peut-être baisser vers 3°gr he
disons que que nous dit le le le bon
sens le bon sens est que euh disons pour
que le réchauffement climatique donc le
bon sens c'est donc capacité
d'adaptation des jeunes d'aujourd'hui
euh limité à à 2 degrés si possible 1
degr 5 on comprend bien que pour et que
pour limiter disons pour stabiliser le
climat il faut disons que l'effet de
serre arrête d'augmenter hein on va
parler de neutralité carbone de façon
assez simple on peut bien sûr discuter
des heures de lautrité carbone mais
voilà et et donc quelques années après
ça dépend là où vous regardez bien le le
climat se stabiliser on comprend bien
aussi que plus euh que plus euh disons
on est ambitieux dans la dans l'objectif
et et bien plus il faudra que cette
neutralité carbone arrive rapidement et
euh c'est très clair donc dans l'accord
de Paris en fait l'accord de Paris met
l'accent sur les 2 degrés he bien en D
de 2 degrés c'est-à-dire que dans
l'accord de Paris on parle d'une
l'atteinte du neutralité carbone dans la
2uxème partie du 21e siècle si vous
relisez l'accord de Paris et c'est
depuis Glasgow effectivement donc il y a
eu le rapport un degré 5 et je salue
Valérie maçon d'mot qui a vraiment joué
un rôle très important dans ce rapport
voilà et j'en profite aussi pour saluer
notre nouveau disons responsable
co-président du du groupe 1 du groupe
scientifique Robert Vautard parce que
c'est très important bien sûr d'avoir le
soutien du du gouvernement vous en
remercie mais c'est très important qu'on
qu'on soit présent voilà donc ce rapport
1 degré 5 qu'est-ce qu'il nous dit on
peut pe passer des heures donc en gros
ça serait quand même plus facile aux
jeunes d'aujourd'hui de s'adapter si le
réchauffement était limité à 1 degr 5
plutôt qu'à 2 degrés he disons chaque
dizaine de degrés compte on pe on peut
parler des enfin il y a vraiment c'est
c'est très clair on va parler des réciif
coréen qui disparaissent complètement à
2 degrés ça va être voilà 10 millions de
personnes de plus pour l'élévation du
niveau de la mer tout ça c'est chiffré
voilà et et et finalement cette idée de
de mettre de privilégier dans l'accord
de Paris 1.5 est quand même passé donc
il y a eu ce rapport c'est 2018 ou 2019
je 2019 mais et ou 2018 le rapport 1.5
et et dans dans la c'est passé vraiment
dans à Glasgow il y a 2 ans maintenant
dans la COP donc en fait on dit
clairement que on a ceci enfin l'accord
de Paris met l'accent depuis la
conférence de Glasgow sur l' 1.5 et donc
sur nité d'une d'une d'une neutralité
carbone à horizon à horizon 2050 alors
euh donc en fait alors le disons les
points positifs c'est que bah 2 ans
après ou même disons déjà bien sûr il y
a déjà une centaine de pays qui ont
affiché d'une façon ou d'une autre dans
le objectifs la neutralité carbone à
raison 2050 c'est positif he voilà c'est
le cas de la France c'est le cas de
l'Europe même la Chine la disons la
l'affiche en 2060 euh même l'Inde et
l'Arabie Saoudite en 2070 donc c'est pas
si mal dans les textes le problème c'est
le fossé entre les textes et la réalité
hein donc voilà actuellement et je vais
venir au au thème qui nous intéresse
actuellement et bien on
a
effectivement on va de façon très claire
vers 3 degrés non pas vers 1 degr 5
autour de 3 degrés alors ément ça dépend
de ce qu'on fait après 2030 ça c'est en
faisant jusqu'en jusqu'en 2030 c'est
l'accord de Paris donc on peut essayer
de voir ce qu'on va faire par rapport ou
non aux engagements il y a différentes
hypothèses mais c'est quand même bien
vers de l'ordre de 3 degrés qu'on on
risque d'aller actuellement têre baisser
en gros le une autre façon de voir les
choses c'est il y a deux fois trop
d'émissions horizon 2030 par rapport à
ce qu'il faudrait par rapport pour avoir
des chances de rester sur 1.5 c'est une
autre façon de le voir donc c'est
aujourd'hui que ça se joue he ça c'est
un message très clair alors disons que
que c'est
important le point important donc je il
y a maintenant des points importants
puisque je vais je vais en venir au
combustible fossile
évidemment quelques chiffres là aussi
donc disons l'augmentation de l'effet de
serre depuis 50 ans c'est 75 % lié au
combustible fossile hein donc c'est un
chiffre très clair du GC euh donc un
point un point peut-être important et là
je reprends texto le le parce que c'est
c'est quand même
important d'avoir ça en tête c'est que
une grande partie je reprends textoau le
rapport du JEC un des paragraphe une
grande partie du réchauffement
climatique d'origine entropique lié aux
émissions de CO2 est irréversible sur
des périodes de plusieurs sèes la
plusieurs millénaires sauf dans le cas
d'une élimination nette considérable de
CO2 atmosphérique sur une longue période
les températures en surface resteront à
peu près constante mais à des niveaux
élevés pendant plusieurs siècles après
la fin complète des émissions
entropiques de CO2 en raison des longues
constantes de temps caractérisant les
transferts de chaleur entre la surface
et l'océan profond le réchauffement
océanique se poursuivra sur plusieurs
siècles en fonction du scénario environ
15 à 40 % du CO2 émis restera dans
l'atmosphère pendant plus de 1000 ans
sont quand même des des il faut
réfléchir à ce qu'on est en train de
faire he c'est ce qu'on est en train de
faire on est en train de mettre du du
CO2 alors on y met allègrement on en a
mis à peu près alors quelques chiffres
37 milliards de tonnes l'an dernier de
CO2 par à cause du combustible fossile
on y ajoute quand même 5 à 6 milliards
pour la déforestation et puis 1 à 2
milliards pour la fabrication du ciment
maintenant pour venir au au au point qui
nous intéresse donc pourquoi ce
moratoire ça a déjà été largement évoqué
merci monsieur le
Président qu'est-ce qui se passe et là
si je reprends le le disons on va pas on
veut stabiliser en fait alors tous les
gaz à effet de serconte par exemple
c'est plus c'est plus court terme pour
le méthane si on regarde la
stabilisation dans la deuxème partie de
ce siècle c'est largement en premier
lieu disons déterminé par la quantité
cumulée de de gaz carbonique que nous
aurons dans l'atmosphère disons c'est
les les le méthane est par exemple moins
important à à échéance de alors il est
très important à court terme un peu
moins important si on se place alors on
essaie de se placer dans la deuxième
partie de ce siècle je le redis le
cumule des émissions détermine pour une
large mesure la moyenne mondiale du
réchauffement he c'est encore un
paragraphe du siè fin due siècle la
plupart des caractéristiques du
changement climatique persisteront
pendant nomieux siècles voilà alors donc
une fois qu'on sait ça ça veut dire que
pour chaque niveau de stabilisation on
est capable de dire ce qui reste ce
qu'il reste ce qui nous reste à émettre
de CO2 hein donc si on veut rester à 1.5
il nous reste pratiquement 5 à 6 années
d'émission au rythme d'aujourd'hui he ça
équivaut à avoir neutralité carbone
disons c'est la même façon que de
descendre très rapidement vers
neutralité carbone à raison 2050 c'est
ça fait à peu près pour voilà donc si on
disons si on si on est si on se
contentait mais de 2 degrés ce qui
serait peut-être déjà pas mal je veux
dire c'est pas si simple bon voilà c'est
plutôt disons une une quinzaine d'années
d'émission au rythme d'aujourd'hui donc
c'est c'est quand même ça le le le le
point de départ alors
ensuite voilà
donc bon alors je vais pas redire vous
l'avez très bien fait
donc redire tout ce que vous avez dit
monsieur le Président sur les bombes
carbones hein c'est très bien documenté
voilà je ne vais pas le redire mais
c'est important c'est-à-dire que d'ors
et déjà on sait qu'il y aura des des
actifs échoués enfin disons si on veut
limiter un degré 5 même à de degrés on
sait qu'il y aura des actifs échoués
alors on peut ne pas le vouloir ça c'est
autre chose ou ne pas y arriver mais il
faut pas disons voilà c'est c'est pas
voilà c'est pas l'un et l'autre hein
donc donc c'est faut voilà donc je je
redis je pas être trop long donc voilà
donc c'est c'est donc ris mais vous
l'avez bien dit aussi que j'ai mis en
avant le rapport du GC mais j'aime bien
aussi parler du rapport à ils sont
vraiment en phase c'est-à-dire que le
rapport de de l'Agence internationale
énergie disons Fati Birol est très clair
dans son rapport 2021 et de nouveau dans
dans les trois scénarios qu'il présente
donc il y a pas disons c'est pas du tout
la disons on peut quand même pour moi la
c'est le porte-parole des énergies
fossiles he donc du du duf voilà c'est
quand même un peu ça même si enfin
disons il y a aussi une agence pour les
énergies renouvelables il y en a une
autre pour le nucléaire mais celle pour
les énergies renouvelables est pas très
V on on l'entend pas beaucoup hein donc
ça c'est il ESS ils essayent je sais
bien mais ils ont un peu de mal bon
voilà mais en tout cas il y a il y a pas
disons il y a il y a pas l'ombre d'une
enfin bon c'est dit différemment mais
vraiment les les chiffres qui sont
repris par la et par par le G sont tout
à fait cohérent c'est c'est pas l'un ou
l'autre les disons après c'est ça peut
être placé de donc voilà donc ça veut
dire quand même que que disons ce du du
point de vue du du pourquoi il y a il y
a vraiment une véritable raison de dire
qu'il faut arrêter d'investir c'est ce
qu'on dit alors après on verra euh bon
c'est c'est alors moi moi ce que j'aime
bien dire quand même avant voilà de
répondre c'est j'aime bien dire parce
que j'aime bien dire que les solutions
existent c'est c'est donc voilà il y a
aussi dans dans le 3ème rapport du
siècle un très beau tableau qui qui nous
dit quoi qui nous dit que si c'est pas
ce qu'on fera mais qui nous dit que si
on avait décidé vraiment de disons de
d'essayer de respecter l'accord de Paris
et bien voilà il faut il faudra gagner
une vingtaine ou 25 milliards de tonnes
de CO2 d'ici 2030 on pourrait on aurait
pu déjà en gagner à peu près 10
milliards avec le le le renouvel
voilà 1 milliard avec le nucléaire 1
milliard à peu près avec le piégeage
stockage du carbone tout ça ça se
décline et le message du disons c'est
pas ça n'aurait pas été techniquement
impossible je dirais pas qu'on en prend
le chemin mais il faut pas dire non plus
c'est pas possible c'est pas possible
c'est pas non plus la fin de de enfin je
veux dire bon j'aime bien aussi parler
de sobriété mais je veux dire ce n'est
pas c'est un autre mode de développement
j'aime pas parler de décroissance du
tout mais je veux dire c'est un autre
mode de développement et cette
transition je dirais simplement qu'on ne
peut pas ne pas la faire he c'est-à-dire
que ne pas la faire ne pas atteindre
notalité carbone c'est accepter que le
climat se réchauffe indéfiniment he donc
c'est quand même cela le le voilà le
débat donc voilà donc je je pense qu'il
y a alors après on peut je pense qu'il y
a de bonnes raisons effectivement de
dire d'une autre façon c'est ce qu'on a
essayé de dire dans dans ce dans cette
proposition de traité enfin bien sûr
dans cet appel à au gouvernement à signé
ce traité non profilation il faut
vraiment un moment que des mesures
soient prises pour que effectivement et
bien on atteigne une notalité carbone on
en prenne le chemin pour peut-être pas
2050 mais j'aimerais bien mais voilà
donc c'est c'est c'est cela et c'est
c'est vraiment très bien documenté du
point de vue du scientifique merci
beaucoup merci Monsieur Josel madame la
ministre je vous donne la
parole merci beaucoup monsieur leés
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les les
sénateurs je veux d'abord vous remercier
pour l'initiative de cette table ronde
et dire que je suis très heureuse d'être
au côté de jean-jousel je vais pas
revenir sur le constat scientifique que
vous avez exposé je crois qu'il est très
clair pour
chacun et que les éléments climatiques
extrêmes de ces derniers mois nous
placent clairement face à c'est c'est la
phrase de cette tribune à un moment de
bascule de notre civilisation euh et je
pense qu'il faut effectivement
pleinement intégrer cette cette image
c'est dans ce contexte qui est
particulièrement inquiétant que je me
rendrai à la COP 28 qui se tiendra du du
30 novembre au 12 décembre à Dubaï et au
fond puisque la question de la sortie
des énergies fossiles est posée je
propose d'abord de d'avoir de remettre
en perspective les efforts de la France
en matière climatique et de vous dire
comment en tant que membre du
gouvernement en charge de cette
négociation climatique j'envisage
d'aborder cette cette
négociation d'abord je vais le redire la
France n'a pas à rougir de ses efforts
durant le premier quinquena du président
de la République la France a doublé son
rythme de baisse des émissions en
comparaison du quinquen de son
prédécesseur le président Hollande et
nous accélérons encore puisquen 2022 nos
émissions de gaz et effet de ser ont
baissé 2,7
%. ce qui nous place aux avant-postes
des pays du G7 en tout cas je parle sous
votre contrôle mais je crois je n'ai pas
vu d'autres pays du G7 qui avaiit une
baisse a marqué et sur le premier
semestre de cette année nous avons
encore baissé nos émissions de 4,3 % ce
qui est considérable il est pas
impossible que le plan sobriété a un
rôle important dans dans cette baisse et
lorsqu'on sait ce que nous a coûté entre
guillemet le plan sobriété je crois que
ça plaide vraiment pour poursuivre dans
cette politique c'està dire peu de
choses si ce n'est quelques efforts et
un peu de discipline ces chiffres ils
sont aussi le résultat de la politique
volontariste que nous menons de depuis 6
ans ce volontar
vous l'avez vu puisqu'il s'est traduit
sur le plan législatif avec la loi
énergieclimat votée en en 2019 la loi
antigaspillage pour une économie
circulaire votée en 2020 la loi climat
et résilience votée en 2021 et les deux
lois d'accélération des énergies
renouvelables et du nucléaire que j'ai
porté devant le le Parlement cette année
et la vocation à se poursuivre avec une
loi sur l'énergie qui doit arriver d'ici
la la fin de l'année pas au Parlement
mais
minima entre les instances de
concertation et et le Conseil des
ministres elle se traduit également par
des actions concrètes afin de
transformer le quotidien des Français
des actions qui reposent sur un principe
intangible la transition écologique et
énergétique ne doit pas
AG vous savez que le gouvernement a
engagé une profonde refonte de
dispositif d'accompagnement de la
rénovation thermique en le ciblant sur
les revenus moyens et modestes et que
vous parliez du projet loi finance
monsieur le Président nous renforçons
les enveloppes significativement en
portant le budget total d'intervention à
5 milliards d'euros pour l'année
prochaine je pense aussi à l'enjeu des
mobilités là aussi c'est un enjeu
d'énergie fossile nous avons une
ambition forte celle de réduire la
consommation de carburant en
électrifiant les véhicules et en
augmentant le recours au transport en
commun et aux mobilités douce évidemment
le le vélo parmi ses mobilités cette
ambition elle se traduit dans
l'interdiction prise au niveau européen
dans notre pque qui est climat fit for
55 de vendre des voitures thermiques à
partir de
2035 et nous allons même plus loin en
étendant ces mesures au poids lourd mais
face à ce changement majeur nous ne
pouvons pas laisser nos concitoyens sans
solution et donc nous devons accompagner
les Français qui sohaitent changer de
voiture c'est tous les enjeux et là
aussi nous renforçons ces aides du bonus
écologique de la prime à la conversion
et dans la les tout prochains jours du
lancement du leasing social à 100 € par
mois pour les voitures électriques
ces actions elles s'inscrivent dans un
changement de méthode la planification
écologique cette planification elle est
portée par le Président de la République
elle a été confiée à la première
ministre et elle a fait l'objet d'un
très important travail interministériel
depuis un an qui a d'ailleurs été assez
largement salué par les experts et les
associations environnementales et qui
constiue pour notre pays un plan de
bataille secteur par secteur avec des
objectifs et des moyens pour les
atteindre cette planification elle doit
guider notre pays vers atteintre de nos
objectifs climatiques réduction de ces
émissions de gaz à effet de serre de 55
% d'ici 2030 sortie des énergies fossile
neutralité carbone net en 2050 euh je
peux dire aussi un mot rapidement de la
finance climat parce que ça fait partie
aussi des moyens de sortir des énergies
fossiles c'est comment on accompagne des
pays en développement dans des projets
de transformation et de sortie des
énergies fossiles du charbon du du fi
lourd la France a déployé 7,6 milliards
d'euros l'année dernière dont 2,6
milliard d'euros consacrés à
l'adaptation c'est un record un record
absolu et vous savez qu'au niveau
international nous avons pris nos
responsabilités en organisant le sommet
pour un nouveau pacte financier les 22
et 23 juin dernier pour lancer une
dynamique pour réorienter les flux
financiers internationaux vers la
finance climat et vers les solutions
décarbonés au fond l'analyse que font
les experts c'est que financièrement
l'argent existe pour soutenir le secteur
énergétique et que l'enjeu ce serait de
réorienter l'essentiel de ces fonds vers
des solutions décarbonées et que les
projets décaronnaé dont on parle je
pense notamment aux énergies
renouvelables dans les pays en
développement sont des projets
compétitifs économiquement donc le sujet
n'est même pas d'un manque de
compétitivité lorsque vous fabriquez du
photovoltaïque dans un certain nombre de
pays en développement le coût euh de
production l'électricité est extrêmement
compétitif c'est valable aussi pour
l'hydraulique donc il y a vraiment des
projets qui aujourd'hui ne sont pas
accompagnés alors qu'il le devrait au
bénéfice de la réduction de nos
émissions de gaz à effet de ser et de la
réduction de notre production et notre
consommation d'énergie
fossile et je pose ce tableau je dis que
c'est très positif que on fait des
efforts qu'on accélère et qu'on accélère
encore et pourtant
lorsqu'on regarde les chiffres très
concrètement même la France qui est donc
à l'avant-garde des pays des G20 dans le
contexte de dégradation de notre puie
carbone euh du fait du réchauffement
climatique du dérèglement climatique
nous avons encore une marche
supplémentaire à franchir et donc vous
avez un phénomène de cercle vicieux je
veux le souligner qui fait que plus le
dérèglement climatique se met en place
plus la marche à franchir est élevé et
plus nous devons accélérer et ça
finalement va dans le sens que plus on
délé enfin on a un délai sur le moment
où on met en jeu des mesures correctives
par rapport au règlement climatique plus
ça coûtera cher et ça coûtera cher
évidemment financièrement ça coûtera
cher économiquement ça coûtera cher
socialement ça coûtera cher en vie
humaine le le deuxième constat au-delà
du du centrage sur la France c'est que
les efforts sont loin d'être
suffisamment partagés et quelque part on
va rentrer en creux dans la mécanique de
discussion et de et de négociation de
nos
trajectoirees climatique
planétaire la construction de capacité
et énme de nouvelles centrales à charbon
sont annoncées de même que
l'exploitation de nouvelles mines de
charbon de nouveaux champs de pétrole de
nouveaux champs de de gaz et on le voit
en Asie au Moyen-Orient et dans les
Amériques de même l'Union européenne est
de loin le premier contributeur à la
finance climat alors que les grands pays
anglo-saxons du G7 et du G20 sont loin
d'avoir fait les mêmes efforts on peut
penser qu'il est regrettable que
seulement trois pays dont la France cons
contribu àprque la moitié du budget du
fond vert pour le climat on peut
également s'étonner que des pays qui ont
bénéficié des prix élevés de l'énergie
l'année dernière par exemple pays du
Golf toujours classé pays en
développement dans les
négociations ne contribue pas plus aux
efforts de solidarité sur le climat et
c'est dans ce contexte difficile que la
France continue à agir et que je
porterai des propositions concrètes pour
la COP 28 et qu'effectivement nous ne
souhaitons pas nous résigner par rapport
à à cette situation mais je veux juste
planter le tableau parce que il y a
effectivement loin de la coupe aux
lèvres
entre promouvoir pour l'ensemble des
pays une neutralité carbone et une
sortie des énergies fossiles et
l'obtenir en sortie de négociation de la
COP 28 alors quelles sont mes priorités
pour la COP 28 nous ne sommes pas sur la
bonne voie pour atteindre les objectifs
de l'accord de Paris j'enfonce une porte
ouverte vous l'avez très bien dit le
bilan mondial que nous négocierons à la
COP doit nous permettre doit nous
remettre c'est l'objectif sur une
trajectoire compatible avec la limite
des 1 de5 ce qui veut dire que
scientifiquement notre position elle
doit
d'être de de soutenir la réduction des
émission de gaz à effet de serre de 43 %
d'ici 2030 ensemble de la planète de 60
% d'ici 2035 par rapport à 2019 et la
nécessité d'atteindre un pic de nos
émissions en 2025
c'est ça mécaniquement ce qu'il faut
pouvoir déployer si on veut tenir cette
trajectoire d' un degré
5 en
2021 nous avions déjà acté la sortie du
charbon et la réduction des énergies
fossiles à Dubaï il faudra aller plus
loin sur ce sujetl autant que possible
la France va pousser du coup dans le
sens de l'inscription de la sortie de
toutes les énergies fossile dans
l'accord final quit à articuler des
formulations qui soient fondées sur les
émissions de gaz et effet de C lié à ces
énergies parce que c'est peut-être le
chemin de négociation qui sera
acceptable et d'obtenir
2030 avec des échéances une réduction
des émissions de de gaz à effet de serre
par ailleurs avec l'Union européenne
nous souhaitons obtenir l'inscription
d'un objectif de triplement au niveau
mondial des renouvelables et de
doublement de l'efficacité énergétique
d'ici 2030 puisque ce
que l'argument qui nous qui nous est
opposé sur les énergies fossiles c'est
dire on ne peut pas mettre à bas le
système énergétique existant sans avoir
commencé à construire le futur système
énergétique donc très bien on prend le
le défi et nous nous proposons de
tripler le haut niveau mondial les
énergies renouvelables et de doubler
l'efficacité énergétique donc de baisser
notre
consommation d'énergie d'ici 2030
objectif rapide à ces objectifs nous
attacherons la reconnaissance des des
autres solutions décarboné dans les mix
énergétiques euh de chaque pays vous me
suivez c'est évidemment le nucléaire
pour la France et l'importance de mettre
en œuvre la sobriété énergétique qui est
euh là aussi pas forcément un sujet très
largement partagé il ne fait pas trop
débat au niveau de l'Union européenne
mais il n'est pas porté non plus et
finalement il y a que deux pays qui le
pent de manière un peu plus volontaire
qui sont la France et et l'Inde et et et
je pense qu'il faut euh s'accorder sur
le fait que c'est pourtant un des
piliers incontournable de notre
politique de transition énergétique à
cette fin nous mettrons en avant les
efforts de sobriété énergétique français
je le rappelle nous avons baissé 12 %
notre consommation de gaz et
d'électricité ces 12 derniers mois c'est
pas juste l'hiver dernier ce qui
explique la forte baisse de nos
émissions de gaz et effeter notamment
dans le secteur du du bâtiment l'année
dernière - 15 % donc il y a vraiment une
relation intéressante entre les deux
éléments dans le même
esprit d'avoir une une vision européenne
nous nous d'avoir une vision sur les
énergies décarbonées nous nous
engagerons avec une coalition de pays à
développer l'énergie nucléaire solution
indispensable à la lutte contre le
changement climatique en dehors de ces
priorités pour les décisions à la COP
qui nécessitent l'accord des 195 partis
je vais participer à des coalitions dont
certaines sont lancées par nos soins qui
visent à faire avancer sur des sujets
spécifiques ces sujets spécifiques ils
sont au nombre de je recomte de qu le
premier sujet c'est le nucléaire avec un
grand événement le 2 décembre il y en
aura deux autres pour montrer que cette
énergie nucléaire est une solution
indispensable dans l'ensemble de la
boîte à outil des solutions encore une
fois pour respecter les 1 degr 5 et nous
adopterons une déclaration conjointe
pour porter ce ce message et je veux
dire que je reviens d'un déplacement à
Bratislava où se tenait une réunion de
l'alliance du nucléaire que j'ai lancé
avec la et à laquelle participe 1 autres
États membres européens c'est cette
alliance est clairement un succès
diplomatique pour notre pays elle a
permis que le mot nucléaire ne soit plus
un gros mot à Bruxelles et elle doit
nous compte elle nous a également permis
de décrocher un accord historique sur la
régulation du marché européen de
l'électricité qui améliore les outils de
financement de nos investissements dans
les énergies décarbonées nucléaire comme
renouvelable le deuxième objet c'est la
sortie du charbon sur la sortie du
charbon notre action elle vise à trois
objectifs donc c'est dans le cadre d'une
coalition à côté de des discussions avec
l'ensemble des États élargir le nombre
de pays qui s'engage à ne pas construire
de nouvelles centrales à
charbon lancer un plan d'action pour
assécher la finance privée du charbon on
a grosso modo un peu près à sécher la
finance publique du charbon les
subventions au charbon
mais la je dirais l'aspect finance
privée n'est pas aujourd'hui réellement
adressé avec la mesure dans la avec
l'appui dans la mesure du possible de
l'OCDE et troisème élément accélérer le
décommissionnement des centrales à
charbon existantes c'est également
l'objet d'un événement le le 2 décembre
trème objet la décarbonation du secteur
maritime en lien notamment avec CMA CGM
et nos partenaires d'Europe du Nord et
des États-Unis vous le savez le
transport maritime émet environ deux
fois plus que le transport aérien c'est
évidemment là aussi la consommation
d'énergie fossile et nous voulons
progresser davantage vers des carburants
propres donc nos fossiles pour ce mode
de transport et le 4ème objet c'est le
méthane les entreprises pétrolières et
gazières doivent faire leur part
et il y a deux combats il y a un combat
qui est vraiment très spécifique sur le
méthane il une start-up française qui a
mis en évidence que les fuites méthanes
sont beaucoup plus importante que celle
qu'on estimait initialement or le
méthane est à l'origine d'un tiers du
réchauffement climatique le méthane a un
grand défaut c'est qu'il est beaucoup
plus réchauffant que le CO2 il a une
grande qualité c'est qu'il disparaît de
l'atmosphère je parle sous votre
contrôle hein je suis pas ingénieur
beaucoup plus rapidement que le CO2 mais
en gros euh traiter très vite ces enjeux
autour du méthane permet d'avoir un
impact réellement rapide sur nos
émissions de gaz et effets de serre la
France pousse ainsi une coalition
d'entreprises pétrolières à faire des
annonces sur la fin des fuites méthan et
du torchage d'ici 2030 au plus tard au
niveau européen l'Union européenne vous
prépare un règlement pour réduire nos
émissions de méthane et la France agit
puisque nous avons fait circuler un nom
papier pour que ces exigences soient
également appliqué à nos importations
sans compromettre notre sécurité
d'approvisionnement je c'estis le la
dérogation l'effort que nous devons
faire pour faire bouger no nos amis
européens c'est clairement le meilleur
moyen aussi pour pousser nos partenair
hors Europe à changé leur pratique et on
voit que ce règlement qui n'est pas
encore adopté bouge un peu les les
lignes puisqu'on a quelques retours par
exemple d'Algérie on commence à
considérer les investissements pour
réduire leur leur fuite méthane
euh sur le plan de la finance climat je
veux juste faire un un un mot sur ça je
veux saluer l'accord qui a été trouvé la
semaine dernière à Abu Dhabi sur sur le
fond pert et préjudice parce que au fond
c'était aussi un sujet qui risquait de
bloquer les négociations à la COP 28 et
c'est pour ça que à titre personnel je
me'y suis beaucoup impliqué en présidant
une réunion sur le sujet lors de la
précope et en rencontrant les acteurs
clés de la négociation l'accord est
trouvé il semble équilibré il devrait
permettre de répondre au mandat de la
COP 27 de charmelcher et donc l'idée
c'est que on fixe ce point et qu'on
puisse du coup vraiment parler
d'atténuation et d'adaptation et de
finance climat qui sont les trois
piliers au fond absolument indispensable
si on veut avoir un un un accord
ambitieux sur sur la COP 28 donc vous
l'avez compris les prochains mois vont
être
décisifs on a pris nos responsabilités
face au secteur pétrolier et gazier en
les associant et en les poussant à
prendre des engagements de réduction
leur émission de gaz et effet de serre
scope 1 scope 2 dès 2030 j'ai
même initié un événement en marge de de
du sommet de Paris de juin dernier avec
le président de la COP Laurence tbiana
John Kerry le président de l'Agence
internationale de l'énergie enfin et les
trois euh patrons de de nos grandes
entreprises européennes donc les deux
françaises total en et
equinor le Norvégien pour les amener à à
soutenir la Global Alliance qui a lancé
les la présidence émirati sur ce sujet
de réduction des émissions de gaz et
effet de serre et notre objectif c'est
effectivement de
cranter diplomatiquement le langage le
plus ambitieux possible et de l'autre
côté par des coalitions de traiter des
sujets spécifiques qui sont autour de la
sortie des des des énergies fossiles
donc un traité de non prolifération dans
les quelques semaines qui viennent sans
doute pas mais une ambition portée par
la France et une position qui permet
point à point d'aller chercher des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre de
remettre les export de remettre les
consommateurs des fossiles face à leur
responsabilité de remettre les
producteurs de fossiles face à leur
responsabilité d'obtenir des avancées
sur la baisse des émissions de gaz effet
de serre à court terme et dans
l'objectif de 2050 certainement c'est ce
à quoi nous allons nous employer la
France est clairement à l'avant-poste du
combat sur son territoire et sur et au
niveau international à l'avantpost pour
que les différences entre pays
n'empêchent pas l'ambition pour que le
cap de l'accord de Paris reste
atteignable et pour que et pour défendre
une transition juste et équitable et
donc vous pouvez compter sur ma
détermination en ce
sens merci Madame la Ministre donc je
vais donner la la parole à Madame
varayas
euh bon je je veux pas être pessimiste
parce que c'est pas mon style c'est pas
mon genre mais c'est la première fois
quand même qu'un présidente d'un groupe
pétrolier est à la tête des négociations
climatiques or nous savons que le
dérèglement climatique est
principalement causé par la combustion
des énergies fossiles et c'est même la
thématique générale de la COP 28
le secrétaire général des Nations unies
Antonio guérz déclaré en avril 2022
notre dépendance aux énergies fossiles
est en train de nous tuer quel signal
quel signal donne le monde en nomant à
la tête de la COP le dirigeant d'une
entreprise qui pompe près de 4 millions
de barils de pétrole par jour un
journaliste
ironé pardon un journaliste
ironisé hier en disant c'est demander la
santé à un funérarium je n'irai pas
jusque-là mais euh j'ai envie de dire
déjà la COP 27 de 2022 en Égypte la
présence de 600 lobéistes des énergies
fossiles avait réussi à contrecarrer les
les propositions les plus ambitieuses
avec la COP à Dubaï on est presque dans
la caricature ces l'obéistes se
présentent comme partie de la solution à
la lutte contre le réchauffement
climatique alors qu'en réalité ils sont
partis du problème et retardent l'action
en défendant la décarbonation la
compensation carbone ou des technologies
de stockage et de captage de CO2 le 30
septembre dernier un collectif appelle
les États à réinventer le modèle des
cops et à les placer sous la protection
des nations- Unies moi j'aimerais savoir
ce qu'en pense monsieur jusel par
ailleurs les engagements pris par les
cops n'étant pas contraignants et nous
le redisons à chaque fois nous étions à
Glasgow nous nous avons nous avons pu
nous en rendre compte se pose
inéluctablement la question de la
sincérité de la démarche qui valorise
les intentions mais sans concrétisation
des engagements pris alors le fond
pertes et dommages prévu par la COP 27
en soutien aux pays les moins développés
qui sont les plus exposés au risques
climatiqu et les moins responsables des
émissions de carbone a suscité de
nombreux espoirs toutefois les récentes
négociations précop ont causé des
désillusions puisque les pays développés
n'ont pris aucun engagement financier
immédiat ou prévu d'échéance de
versement les états Unis vont même
jusqu'à dire nos engagements doivent
rester
volontaires pourtant lors des dernières
copes il a été rappelé que les besoins
en financement pour mener à bien les
politiques d'adaptation et d'atténuation
dans les pays les plus pauvres sélevé à
1300 milliards de dollars par an les
pays riches je le rappelle s'était
d'ailleurs engagé en 2009 à copenhag au
versement de 100 milliards de dollars
par an en direction des pays émergents
bien évidemment ces engagements n'ont
pas été respectés
enfin les banques continuent à financer
les énergies fossiles or nous le savons
si la finance ne s'engage pas peu se
fera alors bien je je pense que nous
n'avons pas tout à fait tort nous
lorsque nous disons c'est pas le climat
qu'il faut changer c'est bien notre
modèle économique madame la
ministre je voulais vous interroger sur
les engagements concrets et
transposables dans le droit
national quels engagements aller prendre
la France
précisément par rapport dans cette à
l'occasion de cette COP vous l'avez vous
en avez en partie développé les grandes
lignes ceci étant dit au projet de loi
de finance 2024 39,7 milliards d'euros
sont évalués comme favorabl à la
transition écologique sur les presque
570 milliards d'euros de dépenses
budgétaires et fiscales recensé si on
note les efforts en matière de
décarbonation des transport de
rénovation des logements jugez
jugez-vous monsieur Josel aussi
d'ailleurs que ces crédits sont à la
hauteur de nos engagements du moins pour
respecter nos
engagements merci je vais donner la
parole à Fabien
genunet merci monsieur le
Président merci à Monsieur jusel pour
ces explications très précises sur le
pourquoi merci madame la ministre pour
le point qu'elle nous a fait sur sur la
situation et la préparation de de cette
COP 28 monsieur le Président si vous le
permettez je voudrais m'arrêter quelques
instants puisqu'on a beaucoup voyagé
autour de la planète à la faveur de ces
discussions et de ces premiers éléments
de réflexion sur un élément
d'actualité chez nous en France et en
particulier en sonelloir puisque ce 8
novembre 2023
restera comme le jour où l'emblème de
l'ancienne centrale à charbon de
montsoléine s'est effondré sur lui-même
alors je ne sais pas s'il faut y voir un
symbole beaucoup plus large que la
simple déconstruction d'une
infrastructure énergétique mais cette
centrale luci3 qui a marqué pendant des
années le paysage de montsoléine et de
notre territoire a alimenter la ville en
électricité grâce au charbon extrait
dans le bassin minier pendant près d'un
siècle et aujourd'hui maintenant que
cette infrastructure est déconstruite et
bien depuis quelques mois maintenant sur
une partie du terrain un champ de 30000
panneaux photovoltaïques alimentent 7000
habitants de la ville et la municipalité
conduite par marieclaude jarot continue
euh euh l'évolution du site avec une
production d'hydrogène et une centrale
biométhane qui sont prévues si vous
ajoutez à cela à quelques kilomètres le
l'importance de la filière nucléaire au
creusaux et à Chalon vous avez lo vous
avez là un symbole qui représente la
mutation euh de beaucoup de nos
départements cette transition
énergétique mais également cette volonté
de
décarbonation et au-delà de ce symbole
je voudrais vous interroger madame la
ministre euh sans reprendre tout ce qui
vient d'être dit sur justement au regard
des enjeux qui ont été rappeler sur la
méthode vous avez dit qu'il y avait
qu'il fallait un changement de méthode
qu'il y avait cette planification
écologique qui avait été mené au niveau
interministériel dans quelle mesure une
fois que les ministères se sont mis
d'accord vous compter finalement faire
adhérer les populations et nos
concitoyens à cette nécessité de
planification des concitoyens qui il
faut bien le
dire vous me l'accorderez ont parfois du
mal un peu à suivre les décisions des de
l'État et des gouvernements puisque
parfois il y a des changements de pied
dans la stratégie puisque parfois ceux
qui ont fermé des centrales nucléaires
sont maintenant les meilleurs promoteurs
et nous vous en faisons crédit madame la
ministre de cette filière nucléaire au
moment où on on a une crise énergétique
on est obligé d'importer de de
l'électricité d'Allemagne ou des
centrales à charbon tournent encore donc
il y a effectivement beaucoup de doutes
lorsque vous rajoutez à cela les fake
news sur les réseaux sociaux vous
comprenez que le français moyen il perd
un peu son latin et aimerait avoir
quelques certitude et donc ma deuxième
question au-delà des efforts pour faire
adhérer les populations c'est est-ce que
vous ne croyez pas que tout de même
cette programmation pluriannuelle de
l'énergie que nous attendons depuis des
années et des années maintenant pour ne
pas dire des mois et bien aurait permis
d'avoir cette clarification sur sur
l'objectif que nous devons atteindre et
comment nous pouvons y aller et puis
sans vouloir être trop long et pour
pouvoir laisser à mes collègues le soin
de vous interroger également plus
globalement là aussi beaucoup de nos
concitoyens et et beaucoup des
parlementaires ici voi le monde tel
qu'il a évolué ces derniers mois avec
une montée des antagonisme entre un
certain nombre de régions du monde avec
le retour de la guerre madame la
ministre est-ce que vous ne considéit
pas que ces menaces internationales sont
également une menace pour cette action
qui doit être une action mondiale
planétaire de coopération naturellement
entre les pays et donc cette montée des
antagonismes pourrait mettre à mal la
nécessité la possibilité même de trouver
des accords entre les pays voilà les
quelques questions que je voulais vous
poser merci monsieur le Président merci
cont tenu du je vais vous donner la
parole pour répondre immédiatement et
puis après je donnerai la parole à
Renaud d carv gilet et les trois
suivants
s' j'y vais sur qui semble être adressé
à la représentante du
gouvernement alors madame varage madame
la signatrice varage j'entends ce que
que vous me dit dit et ça a été un un
reproche qui a été fait au président de
de la COP pardon au président de la COP
28 d'avoir parmi ses mandats puisqu'il
est ministre de
l'Énergie
le d'être à la tête d'un grand groupe
pétrolier moi j'ai appris en classe de
philosophie la la citation de Charles
Peggy le quantisme a les mains propres
mais il n'a pas de bain donc on peut
effectivement se dire que on ne négocie
pas avec les pétroliers et les pays
producteurs et les pays consommateurs et
les pays les plus émetteurs mais à la
fin de la journée si on va être efficace
c'est malheureusement eux qui vont faire
la différence sur la baisse de nos
émissions de carbone c'est-à-dire
qu'effectivement le travail que nous
faisons en français il faut une
exemplarité et c'est essentiel pour
montrer que on donne pas de leçon aux
autres et que nous-même on prend notre
part de cette baisse des émissions de
gaz à effet de serre mais en même temps
si on veut arriver à avoir des
trajectoires de baisse d'émission de gaz
à effet de serre il faut prendre en
considération les plus gros pays
émetteurs et il faut prendre en
considération les plus gros secteurs
émetteurs pour les emmener vers des
engagements et vers des actions qui
permettent de baisser les émissions de
gaz à effet de serre et c'est ce que
nous faisons par exemple sur le méthane
par exemple sur le charbon avec des
négociations alors sur des négociations
comme la COP 28 on est sur un consensus
à 195
pays c'est un exercice qualifiera de
complexe d'où l'intérêt d'avoir des
coalitions latérales qui permet en fait
de faire bouger des plus petits groupes
de pays mais en par effet Tage d'huile
et c'est cette action continue qui fait
que malgré tout si on regarde ce qui
s'est passé entre les accord de Paris
aujourd'hui vous avez eu des décisions
qui ont été prises qui auraient été
inimaginables sans l'accord de Paris la
sortie par exemple européenne de la
voiture thermique était quelque chose
d'inimaginable et qui a été été faite
finalement par cette espèce de de de
d'encadrement progressif des
responsables politiques dans une
direction alors c'est toujours frustrant
mais il y a une réalité de l'efficacité
de ces cops successives voilà est-ce que
ça va assez vite non ça les experts nous
disent il y a un léger problème en votre
degré 5 et la baisse des émissions de de
gaz à fa ser est-ce que c'est pour ça
qu'il faut désespérer certainement pas
est-ce que c'est pour ça qu'il faut pas
parler avec les groupes pétroliers les
groupes gaziers les pays émetteurs
certainement pas ça je je j'en suis
absolument convaincu c'est le meilleur
service qu'on puisse leur rendre c'est
qu'en fait on leur demande rien puisque
on sera entre nous à dire quand même
c'est scandaleux ces gens é mettent du
pétrole mais la France a arrêté
l'exploitation ne donne plus de licence
de pétrole une fois qu'on a fait ça on a
épuisé le sujet sur le territoire
français donc si on veut que les autres
jouent il faut qu'on les mette dans une
négociation c'est vraiment la l'approche
que nous pouvons avoir et en utiliseant
an à certains moment l'opinion publique
à certains moment les ONG à certains
moment les experts enfin c'est un jeu
qui s'articule à certains moment
l'exemplarité de notre pays pour faire
obtenir les choses et je crois que le
président de la COP 28 veut un succès
diplomatique comme tout pays qui prend
la présidence d'une COP et pour avoir un
succès diplomatique l'enjeu que nous
avons nous pays de l'Union européenne
c'est de lui dire que son succès
diplomatique n'est pas un succès dans
antagonisation de tel groupe contre tel
groupe par exemple les groupes des pays
en développement contre les groupes des
pays développés mais que c'est plutôt
d'obtenir des vrais bougés sur les
trajectoires climatiques et c'est tout
l'objet de de la discussion que que nous
menons en ce moment et encore une fois
je je crois que ce qui est en train
d'être fait sur le méthane sur les
énergies renouvelables sur l'efficacité
énergétique sur la la baisse des
émissions SC SC de des des groupes
pétroliers est loin d'être inutile
vraiment sur la question des engagements
on repasse en France puisque c'est la
suite de votre question sur la question
de d'abord de l'argent qui est mis pour
accompagner la la transition énergétique
et écologique euh vous le savez il y a
aujourd'hui 10 milliards d'euros enfin
vous allez le voir concrètement lors
l'examen du budget 10 milliards d'euros
supplémentaire dans nos trajectoire à
partir de 2025 pour accompagner la
transition énergétique cela correspond
euh aux orientations données par le
rapport Pisani mafous euh qui considère
qu'en gros vous avez 60 milliards
d'euros supplémentaires d'investissement
à trouver d'ici 2030 et de manière
récurrente que sur ces 60 milliards
d'euros nous on a un équilibre la moitié
du privé la moitié du public et sur la
parti publi vous avez les crédits état
mais vous avez les crédits des
collectivités locales vous avez aussi
les crédits d'ailleurs d'institutions
comme la Caisse des Dépôts la caisse des
dépôt vient d'annoncer des montants très
importants investis dans la transition
énergétique et pour le moment cette
trajectoire semble bouclé pour être
honnête sur la rénovation thermique où
nous avons augmenté très fortement les
crédits je dirais que ma crainte en
terme de enfin lorsque je vais devoir
rapporter l'année prochaine devant vous
où on en est comment ces crédits ont été
développés c'est plutôt la qualité la
rapidité et l'existence de la filière
pour continuer à mener ces
rénovations thermiques la qualité de ces
rénovations thermiques qui m'inquiète
que le fait qu'on ait suffisamment de
crédit je pense qu'on a enlevé cette
contrainte et que les sujets suivants il
faut maintenant les prendre très
complètement en main euh sur la question
euh monsieur Jeunet alors merci de citer
monsoléine il se trouve que cette table
ronde m'a empêché d'aller assister à euh
la destruction de la dernière tour aér
aéroréfrigérante de cette centrale à
charbon et de montrer la transformation
avec ce projet
photovoltaïque magnifique à quelques
kilomètres de toute la filière nucléaire
je pense notamment à
saint-marcell mais comme ça je peux dire
que je je regrette de ne pas être là-bas
pour le pour le voir au comp notamment
du député
Marguerite comment faire adhérer les
populations les citoyens sur la
planification écologique moi j'ai mené
une concertation publique la
programmation pluriannuelle de l'énergie
qui aujourd'hui couvre la période
2018-2023 donc elle existe bien sur les
années du moment ce qu'on est en train
de considérer c'est la programmation à
venir la programmation plurriannuelle de
l'énergie et la loi sur l'énergie elle a
fait l'objet d'un débat public qui s'est
déroulé
entre octobre et février dernier qui a
donné lieu à un rapport qui a été remis
par la Commission nationale du débat
public en mars à ensuite donner lieu à
des groupes de travail auxquels étaient
associés les euh groupes représentés au
au Parlement et notamment tous les
groupes du Sénat alors eler n'a pas
souhaité y participer directement je ne
vous en fais pas grief mais le fait est
que on vous l'a proposé euh mais et
l'air de l'Assemblée nationale y a
participé donc finalement rien n'est
perdu et on pourra on est à votre
disposition pour vous donner les les les
les suggestions et faire une réunion de
travail sur le sujet
euh donc c groupe ils associent aussi
les associations d'élus les associations
de consommateurs les associations
environnementales les fédérations
d'entreprises et des experts donc le
travail d'association de concertation il
est mené on ne fait pas une
planification écologique dans une tour
d'ivoire ça n'existe pas ça n'existe pas
et ils ont donné lieu sur plein de
sujets à des concertations avec des
sujets qui montrent avec des des retours
qui montrent que c'est pas évident la
concertation sur la décarbonation du
chauffage dans le bâtiment a été
intéressante elle a montré rétiscence
forte sur la transformation du chauffage
gage dans le bâtiment je je je ne peux
que le le noter et d'ailleurs vous en
avez été pour très
nombreux sénateurs et députés le relais
dans des courriers qui m'ont été
adressés donc on voit bien que ce sujet
il est il il va nous demander en fait de
faire un exercice continu de remise à
jour de nos trajectoires et moi je pense
que c'est la la bonne façon de de de
procéder c'est de montrer que de manière
continue on sait exactement où on en est
on a une notion de ce que peut nous
rapporter en base des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre le CO2 et cetera et euh
on est lucide sur le fait qu'il y a des
endroits où il y a encore des gaps et
qui ne sont pas satisfaits je vous
parlais tout à l'heure du du puit
carbone moi quand je vois la différence
entre ce que nous avions dans nos
programmations précédentes sur le P
Carone est-ce que nous avons aujourd'hui
de combien ça nous remonte les efforts à
mener pour baisser nos émissions de gaz
à effet de serre je peux vous assurer
que j'ai les cheveux qui qui se dresse
sur la tête et il va falloir faire des
efforts qu'on ensemble en développant et
des énergies renouvelables et beaucoup
plus vite puisque ce que vous m'avez
remis
comme proposition dans le cadre des
travaux c'est doublement doublement du
rythme de déploiement sur le
photovoltaïque sur le biogaz
quadruplement sur la géother permis
euh 10 GW octroyé dans le prochain appel
d'offre ou dans les prochains appels
d'offre en 2024 enfin 2025 sur l'éolien
marin je vous assure que c'est énorme et
nous lancons les concertations sur ce
sujet-là c'est le maintien de la
trajectoire sur lesoliens terrestre et
c'est de l'autre côté et indispensable
parce que sinon on a un yatus la
poursuite du déploiement enfin
l'extension de la durée de vie de nos
centrales nucléaaires et un nouveau
programme nucléaire et si je et je ne
parle pas de la sobriété et l'efficacité
énergétique qui suppose qu'on baisse
qu'on aille trouver 30 % d'économie
d'ici
2030 donc donc la somme de tout ça fait
que euh si vous retirez un élément de
tout ça le château de carte
s'effondre et c'est ça dont on va
probablement discuter dans dans dans
dans les notamment avec la stratégie
française énergie climat que je souhaite
publier dans dans les prochains un jour
mais sur lequel précisément je fais un
dernier tour d'itération parce que les
les dernières simulations montrent qu'il
y a des curseurs qui continuent à bouger
donc je j'essaie d'avoir la contribution
qui soit la plus comment dire précise et
éclairante et transparente possible et
je le dois à la représentation nationale
c'est une question de principe euh voilà
vous posez une très bonne question sur
le retour de la guerre et les risques
géopolitiques et l'ombre portée que ça
peut avoir sur la COP
28 je dirais que de manière paradoxale
j'ai trouvé que la précope 27 était
beaucoup plus préoccupante que la
précope 28 même s'il y avait clairement
un éléphant dans la pièce dans la
précope 28 la précope 27 il y avait une
tension très forte entre pays en
développement pays développés et pays en
développement faut avoir la notion qu'en
gros
c'est enfin c'est tout le monde sauf
l'Europe les États-Unis
Australie Japon Canada et et Royaume-Uni
donc en fait c'est pas vraiment les pays
en développement vous avez des pays en
développement qui sont beaucoup plus
chers en revenu par tête que la France
mais mais ce sont des pays en
développement le Groupe des
77 historique il avait beaucoup plus de
tension sur ça beaucoup plus de tension
à l'égard de l'Union européenne qu'on
considérit comme cynique parce que ayant
redémarré ces centrales à charbon on a
beau dire qu'on a 0,6 % de centrale à
charbon de de de charbon dans notre mix
énergétique c'est assez indifférent dans
la perception et l'envolet des prix
européens et on entraîné une envolé des
prix aussi sur d'autres marchés
internationaux il y avait énormément de
de tension à notre égard je trouve que
là il y a un peu plus d'équilibre un
sentiment d'urgence et de solennité sur
la situation
géopolitique mais là où je partage votre
préoccupation c'est que ces derniers
jours on assiste à des annulations de
déplacement ou des reports de
déplacement de certains représentants
politiques européens dans des pays qui
soutiennent tel camp ou tel camp et qui
sont pas complètement alignés avec la
position de celui qui se déplace et que
cela peut poser problème dans un mois
lorsqu'on devra négocier tout ça donc
grande vigilance de notre part volonté
de vraiment équilibrer les les propos et
et enfin d'être là aussi le plus sincère
et le plus en responsabilité possible
sur les sujets géopolitiques vous l'avez
entendu avec les prises de parole du
président de la République mais sur les
sujets climatiques
également jel oui merci monsieur le
Président je prends le relais sur
quelques questions euh qui n' pas pas
été enfin disons qui ont été posé madame
la sénatrice donc oui sur sur le fait
j'ai j'ai bien lu cette cette tribune
disons souhaitant
que les la convention climat soit mise
disons sous la responsabilité des
Nations Unies mais c'est le cas donc je
vous rappelle que c'est lanuc
c'està-dire convention climat pour des
Nations Unies pour pour le le changement
climatique donc c'est donc le c'est bien
sous la sous la sous l'ombrelle sous les
GID des Nations Unies je crois que le
problème n pas là mais ça pose la
question quand même moi moi je crois que
le problème n'est pas là c'est-à-dire
que ce que ce que n'a pas la la COP
c'est c'est c'est ce statut je dirais de
droit et de devoir que peut avoir l'OMC
hein bon M c'est c'est ça le problème
c'est pas tellement pour moi c'est enfin
que ce soit sur les Nations Unies c'est
très bien ça l'est alors voilà mais euh
disons il faudra il n'y a pas cette
égalité de traitement bon voilà j'ai je
me souviens d'né JAC qui était très
disons intéressé par la création d'une
OME d'une organisation mondiale de
l'énergie je m'étais impliqué à l'époque
et qui est effectivement si on n pas en
face
l'OMC une OME on peut qualifier disons
qui a des droits et des devoirs
équivalents à ceux de de l'OMC je crois
qu'on aura du mal à y arriver parce que
qu'on veuille ou non on va pas je veux
pas non plus être trop politique mais
les règles de l'OMC ne sont pas du tout
favorables à la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique soyons clair
disons le le capit enfin bon on peut on
peut toujours j'étais avec Pascal l'ami
tout à l'heure encore donc mais mais
vous m'accorderez que l'OMC elle-même a
du mal à fonctionner dans le contexte
golitique j'allis dire c'est pas un bon
modèle mais l'OMC a beaucoup de mal ça
je sais également donc mais mais c'est
en tout cas c'est sur les Nations Unies
mais s'il y a pas s'il y a en gros s'il
y a pas de contrainte s'il y a pas bon
voilà c'est c'est ça tout tout le tout
le problème pour moi c'est faut enfin
j'aime bien dire je vais pas être trop
long mais parce qu'on pose souvent la
question à quoi ça sert les cops moi il
y a il se fait qu'il y a longtemps que
je parle de réchauffement climatique il
y a 20 ou 30 ans anné 90 on parlait
régulièrement d'aller vers 45°grés hein
donc parce qu'on voilà on parlait des
des possibilité d'aller + 4 + 5°gr et et
maintenant on met quand même l'accent
c'est ce qu'on a fait aujourd'hui c'est
on va plutôt vers 3°grés donc c'est
moins mal c'est pas suffisamment bien
mais je veux dire quand on me dit que
les COP disons je crois que cette
synergie entre les le GC et les COP a
relativement bien fonctionné he moi j'ai
eu la chance de participer au de bon
c'est loin d'être suffisant mais faut
pas non plus enfin jeter le bébé je
crois qu' faut plutôt l'améliorer
effectivement effectivement l'idée ça
serait de que que ce soit un peu
contraignant quelquefois les les
objectifs qui sont affichés voilà donc
ça le bon sur ce point-là sur les
banques moi oui j'ai j'étais toujours
très attaché parce que à l'alinéa 3 de
l'article 2 quand même qui est très
important
de disons de de de l'accord de Paris
hein qui engage qui invite les banques à
mettre leur disons fon fctionnement en
phase avec la lutte contre le
réchauement climatique et l'adaptation
c'est clairement écrit cette invitation
bon monsieur le Président longjau vous
l'avez rappeler c'est loin d'être quand
même voilà c'est loin quand même d'être
d'être le cas moi moi j'ai j'ai j'ai
pris comme une bonne nouvelle madame la
ministre tout à l'heure ce que j'ai lu
donc voilà c'est votre disons notre
ministre Bruno lomè qui qui dit que et
c'est très important me semble-t-il que
le disons les fausil vont être en dehors
de l'ISR ce qui n'est pas le cas
actuellement et ça c'est quelque chose
justement c'est quelque chose qui va
dans ce sensl pour moi de façon très
claire donc je je enfin je sais pas oui
voilà donc mais c'est très important en
fait je suis aussi impliqué dans
l'institut de finan dur RF je VO bien
qu'on narrête pas non c'est un point que
que que voilà je pense c'est ça
effectivement parce que le résultat
devrait être effectivement que les
banques investissent moins si ça se met
en place les banques devraient
logiquement investir moins elles le font
encore moi aussi je regrette beaucoup
mais mais ça c'est c'est quelque chose
qui m'a semblé enfin important voilà
donc pour terminer bon monsieur jet moi
pour moi il y a trois mots qui sont
importants qui ont été un peu pour pour
la lutte contre le réchauffement
climatique il y a un qui a été évoqué
par madame la ministre c'est vraiment
les inégalités moi je me suis beaucoup
intéressé à la justice climatique
comment fait-on pour que le
réchauffement climatique n'accroisse pas
les inégalités on va pas rêver ça mais
c'est extrêmement important vous l'avez
cité il y a un deuxième mot sobriété on
en a on l'a cité alors on y va peut-être
à petit quand même hein il faut bon
allez allez bon on va parler mais il y a
un troisième mot je bon voilà et le
troisème mot qui est important c'est la
solidarité et c'est sûr qu'il y a pas de
solidarité internationale et pour moi
effectivement si tout le monde regarde
pas dans la même direction ça sera quand
même difficile donc je je suis enfin en
phase disons ça rend quand même qu'on
veuille ou non ces conflits qui se
passent je pense rendre les les les
négociations plus difficiles même si
vous l' présenté d'une façon pas trop
pessimiste mais quand même les gens
regardent d' aailleurs je dirais soyons
clair voilà donc mer merci je vais
donner la parole à Renand dantc oui
merci monsieur le Président la la
situation actuelle au niveau mondial
donc parce que la la COP et le climat le
sujet est tellement vaste qu'on peut
tirer autant de fil qu'on veut si on
reste sur notre question du jour qui est
qui est la question des fossiles on a
2023 à peu près 2800 milliards
d'investissement sur le secteur
énergétique 1600 1700 milliards sur les
les énergies renouvelables qui qui sont
devenus quand même la source principale
aujourd'hui qui capte l'investissement
et et de de capacités nouvelles et mais
on a 1000 milliards sur sur les fossiles
et notamment toujours beaucoup sur le
pétrole c'est-à-dire que avec ce avec
cette situation là évidemment quand on
investit dans des nouveaux pu de pétrole
c'est pas pour 3 ans c'est pour 20 30 40
ans avec cette situation là ce qu'on
voit au niveau mondial et je vous ferai
parvenir le le rapport climate change
dans dans quelques jours on est en train
de le finaliser comme tous les ans sur
le sur la réalité de l'action c'est que
finalement les les capacités
renouvelables prennent en charge les
besoins énergétiques nouveaux et
notamment les besoins énergétiques
nouveaux des des classes moyennes du
monde qui sont en développement un peu
partout ce qui fait d'ailleurs que
aujourd'hui les les classes moyennes
chinoises ont une empreinte
carbone qui est la même à peu de chose
près que que la nôtre même même dans des
grandes villes africaines il y a des
classes moyennes qui ont des empreintes
carbone supérieur supérieur au nôre et
la vocation du monde c'est que toutes
ces classes moyennes ont une envie d'un
d'un mode de vie qui est pas très
différent du du nôutre euh en disant ça
ce que je dis c'est que euh si on
continue comme ça euh évidemment euh on
sera au mieux vers les 3 degrés ce qu'a
dit jean-jousel euh c'est déjà mieux que
les 5 qui était sur la table et ça dit
effectivement le fait que les copes ne
sont pas inutiles euh mais bon le 1,5°gr
c'est mort enfin on va pas c'est pas la
peine de se de penser qu'on va tenir un
objectif qui serait une rupture totale
en quelques mois ou quelques années et
c'est pas du tout les les les logiques
mondiales des investisseurs même le 2
degrés après Glasgow est très difficile
à atteindre ce qui veut dire que quand
Christophe Béchu dit plus 4 degr ce
qu'on avait été un certainorté c'est
purement lucide c'est en fin à + 4 degr
en France c'est-à-dire le double
d'aujourd'hui quand on voit les les
conséquences aujourd'hui à + 2 degrés on
se dit qu'à + 4 ça va quand même secouer
durement mais donc moi je reste vraiment
sur sur cette COP je ne fais pas tout à
fait dans dans le sens de l'analyse
précédente moi je trouve que c'est
plutôt bien mais là je vais plutôt dans
le sens de la ministre de dire allons
chez les pétroliers pour discuter parce
que la COP esttant un compromis mondial
entre tous autant aller discuter chez
les chez les pétroliers mais là du du
coup la France est une puissance
mondiale énergétique et financière je
parle pas de nos 0,9 ou 1 % d'émission
elle fait globalement effectivement
l'Union européenne aujourd'hui est dans
une logique de de réduction de ses
émissions et la France est est tout à
fait dans dans dans la dynamique
européenne moi je parle de la France
comme puissance euh qui a de très grands
groupes énergétiques et notamment un des
très grands groupes pétroliers euh je
parle de la France qui est un pays qui
abrite de très grandes
banques et est-ce que cette France là
montre le chemin ce qui est pas la même
chose que la France qui qui diminue ses
ses émissions dans dans dans le cadre
européen du du du
50 aujourd'hui et et ça ça on la voit
pas cette France là c'est-à-dire que si
si nos major à nous continue de dire que
on va produire encore un peu plus de
pétrole cette année année précédente le
le signal est assez dramatique et c'est
pas du scope 2 al j'entends bien que en
scope 2 on a des enjeux de de baisse
notamment des émissions de méthane li au
torchage et que ça aura quand même un
impact à l'échelle planétaire mais enfin
ça aura pas non plus l'impact un impact
de de à la hauteur des enjeux or
aujourd'hui on ne voit pas euh où est le
contrat avec les grandes majores
pétrolières le contrat qui était un peu
sur la table que les Norvégiens avaient
un tout petit peu dessiné c'est dire le
le bénéfice du pétrole et diocè s'il y
en a le bénéfice des énergies fossiles
c'est grande major énergétique le
réinvestissent massivement dans le
développement des renouvelables c'était
ça à peu près le le le deal non écrit
mais enfin et or ce deal n'apparaît pas
du tout aujourd'hui compris la stratégie
totale mais c'est le cas de la plupart
des majors il y en a une ou deux qui qui
vont qui qui aujourd'hui mettent sur la
table des des trajectoires qui qui qui
sont compatibles avec le 2 degr ou voir
le 1 5 mais surtout le 2 mais c'est pas
le cas de total c'est pas le cas de
Total euh la plupart de ces majors ne
communiquent pas sur la réalité de leurs
investissements ENR voir les mélanges
avec le gaz donc tout est un peu perdu
et dans le gaz il y a du gaz
conventionnel et du gaz de chiste qui
n'ont pas du tout la même emprun de
carbone en plus enfin bref on n pas
aujourd'hui donc moi ma question madame
la ministre c'est est-ce que euh la
France l'État français est capable
d'amener ces grandes entreprises à
prendre des engagements et l'engagement
le seul engagement qui permet de tenir
demain la trajectoire c'est qu'il y a
une baisse drastique par les majors
pétrolières de leur investissement
pétrolier en
réinvestissant leurs bénéfices
effectivement en restant dans
l'énergétique et en restant de très
grands groupes mondiaux mais en les
investissant massivement plus vite dans
les EnR or ce signal là on le on ne le
voit pas même si évidemment elles en
font un peu elles en font toujours un
peu mais
total en France par exemple n'est
toujours pas dans le dans le top 3 des
ENR malgré sa puissance
économique mais et donc donc est-ce
qu'on peut imaginer qu'à la COP il y ait
des engagements des pétroliers pour
augmenter fortement la part de leurs
résultats réinvestis dans les Hir et ça
vaut aussi évidemment pour les grandes
banque globalement c'est un rapport de 1
à 6 qu'il faudrait aujourd'hui elles
sont dans un rapport de 1 ouais voir
moins de 1 et il faudrait qu'elles
investissent six fois plus dans les EnR
que dans les
nouveaux pu de pétrole ou la recherche
exploitation gaz compris pour qu'on
tienne à peu près les objectifs donc
est-ce que vous pensez qu'on peut avoir
à la COP je sais que la question n'est
pas facile mais avoir à la COP des
choses qui vont dans ce sens là et qui
crédimiser les choses et deuxième
question sans être trop long
complémentaire et je reviens un peu sur
la
France mais un peu dans cette logique là
il y a toujours quelques contradiction
quand même il y a notamment une
contradiction assez forte dans la
stratégie de l'État par rapport au
groupes investis sur les énergies
renouvelables alors on a on a tous nos
mécanismes de prix garanti en France et
d'ailleurs en clair si le le prix de
vente est inférieur au coût de
production l'état paye et si le coût de
vente est supérieur au coût de
production l'état récupère je simplifie
c'est un peu plus complexe mais c'est à
peu près ça sauf que en fait euh l'État
français a globalement plutôt ber mais
bien sûr pris la quasittalité voire la
totalité du bénéfice supplémentaire des
groupes par rapport au contrat de départ
et aux appels d'offre ce qui fait qu'on
a des groupes dont on réduit la capacité
capitalistique à accélérer sur leur
investissement de NR et ça c'est alors
il s'agit c'est pas tout mais c'est
entre entre surprofit et empêcher
finalement ces groupes là et on a
récupéré beaucoup plus d'argent sur les
EnR que sur les surprofits pétroliers
des groupes
français et et que donc là on voit pas
la stratégie
effectivement cohérente globale qui fait
que on mobilise suffisamment de
financement pour encore accélérer donc
il y a encore un certain nombre de de
contradiction mais la question
fondamentale c'est effectivement est-ce
que les pétroliierers viennent à la C
pour dire on va changer les ratios
d'investissement entre le fossile et les
ENR merci je donne la parole à RV
gilet merci monsieur le Président merci
madame la ministre et Monsieur Jean
jousel euh un des plus grands des enjeux
je crois aujourd'hui dans le contexte
aussi international mais pas
exclusivement c'est bien de de lutter
contre le sentiment d'impuissance euh
alors aujourd'hui le débat avec les
climatosceptiques semble dépasser et
pourtant il nous a agité dans cette
maison mais peut-être pas total derrière
l'ancien l'ancien débat il y a aussi la
montée en puissance euh du du de la
pensée comme quoi la science devrait
tout résoudre et que à la limite on n
pas besoin forcément de de changer nos
comportements et même en autre sain
aujourd'hui il y a aussi toujours ce
débat là de dire bah la France
aujourd'hui c'est 67 millions
d'habitants c'est moins de 1 % des gaz à
effet de serre au niveau mondial même si
les habitants sont au niveau mondial à
plus de 7 milliards aujourd'hui et et
c'est un sentiment qui roule assez
régulièrement pour dire pourquoi faire
des efforts dans notre pays puisque on
pèse relativement peu au niveau mondial
bien évidemment nous sommes nombreux
bélayer ce genre de remarque mais il
n'empêche il faut quand même lutter
politiquement sur ce sujet-là et
j'aimerais aussi avoir votre sentiment
de quelle manière on peut le faire d'une
manière peut-être plus forte et plus
dynamique parce que parfois il constitue
un frein qui est quand même relativement
important en corollaire bien sûr il y a
toujours cette question de
l'acceptabilité économique sociale et
politique c'est bien un corollaire des
éléments que que j'ai pu aborder à ce
niveau-là mais pour revenir à la COP 27
la COP 28 et la remarque de marieclaude
varayas sur le la création du fond
d'aide pour les pays effectivement un
des objectifs que vous étiez fixé vous
pouvez peut-être nous en reparler
peut-être que vous l'avez fait mais j'ai
pas forcément bien compris était
justement de revenir sur l'application
de de ce fond avant la COP 28 et de voir
de quelle manière il pourrait réellement
s'appliquer alors est-ce que vous pouvez
nous clarifier votre stratégie en la
matière puisque les échéances
aujourd'hui effectivement se rapprochent
un un deuxième sujet qui émerge aussi
aujourd'hui c'est comment décorréler
aujourd'hui les investissements des flux
classiques au niveau financier voir des
flux monétaires et créer véritablement
les conditions d'autres conditions de
pouvoir investir alors la fiscalité
carbone où nous en sommes aujourd'hui
quel sont les objectifs de développement
de cette fiscalité que ça soit à
l'échelle européenne ou à l'échelle
mondiale comment essayer d'induire
d'autres flux qui nous permettent
d'aller plus vite et plus fort donc quel
est votre avis également sur ce sujet-là
et enfin pour revenir à à à la France
mais sur des objectifs qui devrai être
plus partagés et par rapport à ce que
disait ronand d'antech pour peut-être se
fixer à ce moment-là des objectifs plus
forts en terme de conditionnalité et de
conditionnalité avec un ensemble de
parties prenantes et notamment des
grands groupes si néanmoins c'est
possible nous-même sur nos politiques
publiques reconnaissons que nos
conditionnalités sont encore
relativement faibles pour accompagner
notamment quand vous parlez des
objectifs de la planification écologique
et énergétique ils sont relativement peu
déclinés en terme de conditionnalité et
les conditionnalités à l'échelle
européenne notamment et à l'échelle
internationale sont encore relativement
faibles sur ces sujets quel avis
pouvez-vous avoir et vous parliez des
des coalition et de l'intérêt des
coalitions on ressent pas non plus la
coalition européenne quelque part dans
la stratégie de la COP 28 dans la
stratégie de la cop28 est-ce qu'il y a
une vraie stratégie européenne
aujourd'hui alorsand il même nous
éclairer sur le sujet je vous en
remercie merci je vais donner la parole
à Pierrejean
Rochette merci président madame la
ministre vous avez partiellement répondu
tout à l'heure à une question mais pas
entièrement donc je je peux me permettre
de de la compléter de compléter ma
question vous l'avez dit le méthane est
à l'origine d'un tiers du réchauffement
climatique et comme vous l'avez aussi
parfaitement dit c'est un gaz qui a un
poir réchauffant important 25 à fois 28
fois plus important que le CO2 pourtant
c'est le sujet qui a été insuffisamment
traité jusqu'à présent lors de la COP 26
à glasgo 130 pays dont l'Union
européenne et les États-Unis se sont
engagés à réduire 30 % leurs émissions
de méthane d'ici à 2030 si cet
engagement est tenu s'il est tenu il
pourrait permettre d'éviter
0,2°gr de réchauffement à l'horizon 2050
alors qu'une nouvelle COP va s'ouvrir
dans quelques semaines où en sommes-nous
de la mise en œuvre de cet engagement et
comptezv mobiliser plus largement les
entreprises privées à l'occasion de la
COP 28 pour réduire leurs émissions voyz
j'ai été concis merci très bien merci
encore des encouragements merci très
bien merci c'est parfait euh je vais
donner la parole à Michael Weber
oui monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre monsieur jusel c'est un échange
qui effectivement est intéressant alors
je vux pas reprendre tout ce qui a été
dit parce que et notamment
l'intervention de r Renaud dantech dans
laquelle je me retrouve euh simplement
je fais effectivement remarquer aussi et
de redire que quand on regarde les méga
bombes de carbone qui sont
aujourd'hui partout développé au niveau
mondial effectivement on a un grand coup
français Total qui et le deuxième à le
en nombre à le développer à les soutenir
et nous avons des organismes bancaires à
mon sens trop nombreux alors vous avez
bien sûr parlé qui les soutiennent aussi
et vous avez bien sûr parlé de
l'assèchement hein je je cite c'est bien
le mot que vous avez employé tout à
l'heure euh sans dire exactement enfin
ou en tout cas plus précisément ce que
cela supposait comme action que vous
souhaitiez mettre en œuvre pour aller
vers cet assèchement et puis deux autres
sujets quand même que je voulais aborder
quand on parle des énergies fossiles et
je voudrais avoir aussi l'avis de de de
jean- jousel sur cette question là
puisque le territoire qui est le mien
laamouselle évoque l'hydrogène blanc
actuellement et c'est un sujet sur
lequel alors parce que bien sûr on nous
parle de l'hydrogène comme une des
alternatives possibles jeis d'ailleurs
j'ai beaucoup de doutes moi-même sur la
production d'hydog qui est elle-même
consommatrice d'énergie mais quand on
annonce qu'il y a une ressource présente
sur le territoire français d'hydrogène
blanc qui est aussi une énergie fossile
et que parallèlement et bien on consit
que c'est une énergie propre je
m'inquiète en tout cas je me pose la
question et peut-être av on eu des
réponses pour savoir si c'est une des
réponses effectivement en terme de
besoins d'énergie tel que tel que ça se
présente à nous aujourd'hui et puis
dernière chose quand même que je
souhaitaer souligner on a beaucoup parlé
notamment de la loi d'accélération des
énergies renouvelables euh je pense que
notre pays a eu a pris du retard moi je
là encore je suis sur un département qui
est frontalier avec nos voisins
allemands alors on peut critiquer le
choix qui a été fait par l'Allemagne
notamment de se lancer peut-être il y a
plus longtemps notamment vers du
photovoltaïque peut-être de l'éolien la
réponse en tout cas le courelaire ça a
été le développement d'un certain nombre
de centrale à charbon c'est vrai parce
qu'il n'avait pas d'énergie nucléaire
mais parallèlement aujourd'hui chez nous
c'est un peu la
course et je crains que l'impact sur les
territoires soit soit délé terire Mo
enfin ce que j'entends et ce qui ce que
me rapporte un certain nombre de de
collègues élus notamment sur
l'agrivoltaïisme qui est devenu un effet
d'ben sur la
méthanisation la biomasse qu'il a encore
où on détourne je crois tout à fait les
objectifs qui était poursuit au départ
m'inquiète et et et là encore je je je
je m'interroge à la fois sur
l'anticipation qui a été la notre et
surtout sur l'impact qui pourrait y
avoir demain et finalement à se demander
si la solution qu'on a essaie de
construire ne répond peut-être pas tout
à fait aux objectifs qui devaient être
encourus merci merci je vais donner la
parole à Alexandre wiy merci monsieur le
Président merci à Monsieur Josel pour
son exposé à Madame la Ministre pour
pour sa présentation cette COP 28 elle
est placée sous le sous le signe du du
bilan vous avez dit tout à l'heure
madame la ministre que nous étions en da
de nos objectifs on est autour de 2,5 %
de réduction annuelle et qu'il faudrait
sur la période qui s'ouvre devant nous
atteindre ,8 5 % de réduction annuelle
pour que nous tenions pour que nous
tenions nos objectifs et donc dans ce
dans dans cette réduction C objectif de
réduction on a un point noir qui est la
question des transports vous l'avez
évoqué et je dirais qu'on a un point
pour moi aveugle qui est la question du
transport aérien qui est un secteur
absolument dynamique très dynamique plus
50 % entre
1990 et 2019 qui est dynamique et dont
donc l'ampleur l'ampleur ne fait que
qu'augmenter et sur et sur ce point-là
j'aimerais avoir votre vision de la
planification puisque je comprends que
les chiffres du transport aérien
international de la France ne sont pas
comptabilisés dans les chiffres des
émissions de la France or ce secteur
présente à mon avis deux enjeux majeurs
pour nous d'abord nous sommes un grand
pays de tourisme et donc la transition
dans ce secteur est particulièrement un
enjeu particulièrement important et
deuxième point il me semble que c'est un
secteur dans lequel les alternatives
technologiques sont très faible
aujourd'hui ou quasi inexistante et donc
j'aimerais avoir votre votre votre
sentiment sur comment on planifie ce
secteur moi je je vous donne un exemple
local moi je suis élu de looise dans
l'Oise nous avons un aéroport qui est
l'aéroport de beauvet qui est en fait le
terminal 4 de l'aéroport Roissy Picardie
pour dire les choses simplement qui a un
aéroport qui a aujourd'hui le volume un
volume de de de rotation qui est
équivalent à celui de Nantes aujourd'hui
dans cet aéroport on prévoit des des des
centaines de millions d'euros
d'investissement pour encore l'agrandir
moi j'aimerais savoir comment l'État par
rapport à ces agrandissements
d'infrastructur aéroportuair qui sont en
contradiction nette et et indépassable
en fait avec les objectifs climatiques
se propose d'encadrer les choses pour
éviter que le développement du transport
aérien continue de d'atteindre nos nos
objectifs climatiques voilà j'aimerais
que sur ce secteurl on puisse trouver
avoir des des réponses un petit peu
précises sur ce qu'on mettrait comme
contenu dans la plaification et puis
vous disiez vous disiez au début de
votre votre intervention madame la
ministre que les questions de justice
sociale elles sont essentielles dans la
transition il semble que ce secteur de
de l'aviation est un secteur qui est
particulièrement utilisé par les plus
gros émetteurs je rappelle les chiffres
que donnait Lucas Chancel sur les
émissions 10 % des plus riches de de ce
pays et mettent 5 fois plus que les 50 %
les plus pauvres et donc si on veut
faire dans la justice il faut aussi
s'attaquer à ces secteurs à ces secteurs
je vous
remercie je vais donner la parole à
Simon hen
merci monsieur le Président merci à
Monsieur jusel et merci à Madame la
Ministre moi je voulais simplement vous
dire j'ai eu l'occasion d'en échanger
avec Monsieur jusel en arrivant moi
j'étais à posenan en 2008 donc il y a 15
ans et je vous avoue qu'en 15 ans je
regarde aussi ronant Dantec je veux pas
dire que rien n'a bougé parce que ce
serait largement excessif mais malgré
tout malgré tout les débats que
j'entendais à posznan en 2008 sont quand
même loin d'être très éloignés de ce que
nous avons encore encore aujourd'hui
c'est vrai pour la France c'est vrai à
l'échelle européenne et et international
toujours le sentiment et là encore une
fois les tors sont partagés mais que les
uns et les autres essayent de trouver
des prétexte des raisons pour ne pas
aller assez vite et de ne pas faire face
à l'urgence parce que les scientifiques
en effet monsieur jusel nous disaient
déjà en 2008 ce qui nous attendait
malheureusement l'accélération a été
encore plus brutale et aujourd'hui nous
sommes sur cette ligne de crête madame
la ministre je partage complètement
quand vous dites que il est plus
efficace et plus intéressant y compris
au plan financier d'investir dans le
préventif que dans le curatif on est sur
cette ligne de crête où euh on est
tantôt dans le curatif et tantôt dans du
préventif mais juste avant le curatif eu
et s'agissant de la France je vais pas
revenir sur ce qui a été dit mais c'est
en effet l'un des pays qui se réchauffe
le plus vite vous avez été euh
finalement euh plutôt dans
l'autosatisfaction hein sur les les
objectifs par rapport au au feed for 55
parce que très clairement ces dernières
années la tendance montre bien que nous
sommes assez loin de l'atteinte de ces
objectifs que par ailleurs même s'il y a
une progression elle est en grande
partie liée à la sobriété contrainte que
vous avez que vous avez mentionné
sobriété contrainte qui pénalise quand
même plus fortement euh plus fortement
les les les plus modestes et c'est là où
je rebondirai sur ce que monsieur jusel
a dit tout à l'heure euh quand il disait
il faudra veiller et il a tout à fait
raison à ce que le réchauffement
climatique n'accentue pas les inégalités
il faudra également veiller à ce que la
lutte contre le réchauffement climatique
n'accentue pas les inégalités parce
qu'aujourd'hui on le voit bien euh
notamment dans les territoires ruraux
c'est une une vraie difficulté de la
même façon madame la ministre sur les
moyens financiers fait le rapport Pisani
évoque 66 milliards d'euros 34 milliards
euh donc un petit peu plus de la moitié
pour la puissance publique le vrai sujet
c'est euh euh sont véritablement des
crédits nouveaux et pas du recyclage de
crédit on a bien entendu les annonces de
de la première ministre mais il y a
quelques doutes et puis au-delà de ça on
met dans un même package des dépenses de
collectivité qui sont elles aussi
contraintes qui n'ont pas leur les
marges de manœuvre souhaité au plan
fiscal et et financier et là j'ai
l'exemple des régions très clairement on
parle énergie fossile COP 28 euh les
dernières recettes des régions sur
lesquelles en tout cas elles ont la main
euh ce sont des des taxes liées aux
énergies fossiles l'assise sur l'essence
les cartes grises donc on on a plusieurs
reprises les uns et les autres demander
à ce que ce modèle de financement soit
revu de fond en comble lors du débat PPL
sererme on a insisté sur la nécessité de
mettre en place un versement mobilité
additionnelle justement le partenariat
collectivité entreprise c'est aussi
gagnant évidemment au niveau
international je partage bien mais aussi
au niveau local et et national et puis
là globalement on le voit bien l'enjeu
pour la France c'est vrai au niveau
européen c'est vrai au niveau
international c'est la question de la
crédibilité de sa parole de son
exemplarité je je rejoins ce qui a pu
être dit au niveau européen on voit des
dynamiques plutôt favorables mais encore
une fois les uns les autres nous ne
sommes pas à la hauteur du moment sur le
nucléaire on peut être d'accord pour
dire que ça doit faire partie du mix
énergétique mais le nucléaire ne doit
être qu'une énergie de transition unee
énergie de transition parce que l'autre
gr l'autre grand enjeu c'est l'autonomie
énergétique et le nucléaire
ne résout pas cette question et donc la
priorité c'est l'investissement dans les
énergies renouvelables et là je voudrais
vous donner un exemple madame la
ministre l'hydrolienne
d'Ouessant vous connaissez la situation
de l'entreprise qui a porté ce projet
aujourd'hui on est face à un mur et je
je sais que vous avez été informé de
cette situation où faute de prix de
rachat l'hydrolienne
pourrait pourrire au fond de la mer donc
ça c'est quand même une une vraie
difficulté comment on est capable là
aussi parce que l'urgence est là sur une
île qui en 2020 consommait 2,6 millions
de litrees de fiou par an donc sur les
énergies fossiles on sait très bien que
les îles doivent être aux avant-postes
de la décarbonation mais là aussi il
nous faut des moyens très concrètement
pour passer des paroles aux actes puis
dernière question sur la communauté
scientifique moi je suis assez d'accord
vous avez réagi madame la ministre tout
à l'heure je pense que le combat contre
le climatoscepticisme il reste plus que
jamais d'actualité j'ai eu l'occasion
lors de l'audition de la de la PDG de
Météo France lors de son audition pour
le renouvellement de son mandat de de
l'interroger sur le sujet notamment
auprès des jeunes générations parce que
on le voit y compris des élus moi je le
vois en Bretagne qui sont capables de
dire bah regardez il pleut il fait froid
en plein été il y a pas de réchauffement
climatique tout ça relayé par les
réseaux sociaux donc je je simplifie
volontairement le le trait mais ça a un
impact ça a un impact et comment la
parole que vous portez vous en tant que
scientifique qui parfois a du mal je
pense à à
convaincre peut être mieux et davantage
relayé notamment auprès des jeunes
générations ça nous semble être un
combat tout à fait
essentiel merci y a-t-il d'autres prises
de parole parce que je vous informe que
celles et ceux qui sont membres de la
commission mixte paritaire sur la
sererme je souhaiterais qu'on puisse en
toucher de mot
avant de partir à l'Assemblée nationale
voilà s'il y a plus d'autres prise de
parole je vais laisser la parole à
Madame les ministres ou à jean-jousel
comme vous voulez allez-y bon
alors
attendez hop là je repars monsieur
Dantec monsieur le sénateur
Dantec alors sur la question de la
France comme grand pays
puisque grand pays qui accueille le
siège social de grandes entreprises qui
euh soit au titre de leur activité euh
pétrolière et gazière soit au titre de
leur activité de financement qu'on ont
un rôle sur l'équation du réchauffement
climatique euh deux choses la première
chose c'est que nous on a effectivement
porté cette vision d'un engagement qui
soit au travers de la Global Alliance
qui avait mise en place les Émirats
arabes unis sur des engagements de
réinvestissement dans les énergies
renouvelable qui soit porté par les par
les grands acteurs sincèrement on n' pas
eu un soutien très très très large
compris en Europe on va reparler tout à
l'heure du mandat européen mais on n pas
eu un soutien très très large y compris
en Europe et et j'écoute avec intérêt ce
que vous me dites sur la Norvège mais il
arrive kekinor sont pas forcément le
plus grand investisseur dans les
énergies renouvelables disponibles
ouais enfin ouais enfin le fond Norges
machin bon euh c'est c'est un peu ça
c'est un peu lointain je si je puis me
me permettre euh par contre les
bénéfices on les a bien vu euh pour le
commerce extérieur de de la Norvège
puisque je suis un des très grands
importateurs de gaz norvégien j'ai
vraiment j'ai remercie leur soutien
pendant cette crise que nous avons
traversé euh et on continue à importer
beaucoup pour redistribuer hein chez nos
voisins on est maintenant une plateforme
d'entrée euh du gaz euh norvégien mais
euh peut-être pour le le remettre en en
perspective alors
euh nous ce ce qu'on on a fait d'abord
c'est que effectivement au niveau des
banques il y a des engagements qu'on a
obtenu parce que moi j'étais à berc à ce
moment-là je me rappelle tout à fait de
l'événement qu'on et et de la
négociation qu'on avait eu avec Bruno Le
Maire avec les grandes banques de place
pour qu'elle sorte des énergies fossiles
il y a un engagement de sortir d'ici
2030 pour les financements fossiles dans
l'OCDE et d'ici 2040 pour les
financement fossile hors OCDE ça c'est
le le premier point le deuxième point
qui vous a renvoyé à régulièrement par
les les entreprises qui
participent des énergies fossiles soit
en titre au titre de la production au
titre du financement c'est mais pardon
le scope 3 c'est les consommateurs
baisser la consommation les projets
suivront ce qui est pas complètement
infondé d'où le fait que nous nous
essayons de travailler sur des baisses
de notre
consommation de carburant et de gaz au
niveau européen qui a des grands marchés
et qui permet de dire bah si on fait -
50 - 80 - 100ici avec des date euh vous
voyez bien qu'il se passe quelque chose
et que donc il va falloir adresser ce
marché et répondre à nos besoin de
biocarburant d'énergie renouvelable
d'énergie nucléaire enfin tout ce qui
n'est pas fossile ça c'est la première
piste de de travail qui aujourd'hui est
encore assez c'est peu mature hein pour
le dire clairement à part le charbon sur
lequel on a des euh des dates qui sont
articulées mais qui sont pas forcément
d'ailleurs partagé par par tout le monde
euh la France en tout cas a clairement
indiqué aussi sur le charbon une une
sortie en avant 2030 2027 pour nos
centrales à charbon puis après il y a
l'utilisation dans les processs sur
lequels on a des feuilles de route aussi
pour pour adresser ces ces sujets là
dans les process industriels c'est un
sujet de nature quand même assez
différente euh voilà et puis deuxième
chose vous m'interrogez sur euh la non
enfin le fait que nous ayons taxé les
surprofit des énergies renouvelables je
vais être très clair on a taxé les
surprofit des énergies renouvelables sur
un modèle de CFD qui est celui que
recommande l'Union européenne sur
l'ensemble de la plaque européenne et
que nous avons et que j'ai négocié dans
le cadre d'électricité market design
donc on peut pas nous reprocher d'être
parfaitement cohérent dans cela et on
est parfaitement cohérent puisqu'on
naffirme que sur le nucléaire il faut
avoir la même approche nous avons taxé
les raffineries nous avons taxé euh les
producteurs gaziers alors pas les toutes
petites PME qui restent encore qui
sincèrement on n'allait pas apporter
grand-chose au sujet euh et et donc et
nous avons taxé DF et DF en règle
générale dans les auditions qui peut
faire le rappel assez assez
régulièrement donc on tout le monde est
passé euh à la taxation au moment où euh
on a capté certains éléments de
surprofit qui étaient captabl au niveau
du territoire français et on les a
redistribué au consommateur sous forme
de bouclier énergétique au passage au
bouclier énergétique gaz est une
subvention
fossile d'indemnité pardon le le
plafonnement pas le plafonnement le si
la la ris tourne carburant qui a été
réclamé à cor ETAC par cette assemblée
est une subvention fossile
massive donc non mais ça je pense que ça
met bien en jeu les les les dilemmes
parce que je pense que c'est cette
nature là les dilemmes auquels nous
sommes constamment confronté entre la
question d'une transition juste et qui
n'impacte pas les plus modestes de
manière plus forte que les plus riches
et c'est pour ça que nous avons plaidé
pour une indemnité carburant qui soit
effectivement beaucoup plus dirigé
notamment qui n'adresse pas les les plus
riches mais mais c'est pas inutile de le
rappeler sur monsieur gilet moi je et
vous êtes plusieurs l'avoir dit le
climatoseptici il monte en France vous
avez une étude très intéressante de la
Fondation Jean jorè
qui qui montre
que 40 % des Français reprennent à leur
compte en étant d'accord ou plutôt tout
à fait d'accord ou plutôt d'accord
l'intitulé complotiste suivant le
dérèglement climatique est un prétexte
j'essaie de bien le dire des
gouvernements mondiaux pour imposer des
restrictions de Li au
peuple 40 % et dans ces 40 % il y a 20 %
des Français qui disent qu'ils sont tout
à fait
d'accord donc oui la question c'est pas
tellement la question du réchauffement
climatique ça je pense que tout le monde
le le reconnaî mais la question 1 de
est-ce que le dérèglement climatique est
un phénomène lié à l'homme vous avez une
première série de personnes qui sont pas
tout à fait d'accord avec ça et deuxème
question et que faut-il faire pour
répondre à ce dérèglement climatiqu et
là vous avez beaucoup de personnes qui
vous expliquent qu'il faut surtout pas
faire ce qu'on est en train de faire
c'est-à-dire mettre en place des
véhicule électrique d'ailleurs vous avez
aussi beaucoup de complotisme sur le
véhicule électrique donc je le redis le
véhicule électrique c'est de à 5 fois
moins d'émissions qu'un véhicule
thermique vous pouvez le tourner comme
vous voulez c'est une réalité physique
et à forceuie dans un pays qui a un
système électrique décarbonés à 90 % là
vous êtes sûr de pas perdre euh
doncé voilà donc voilà mais non mais
j'alerte parce que moi c'est quelque
chose que je trouve très
inquiétant alors quelles sont les
réponses que l'on peut faire je pense
que une des réponses c'est de comprendre
c'est deux choses enfin oui c'est trois
choses c'est un il y a des solutions
elles sont à porté de main c'est-à-dire
que on oppose fin du mois et fin du
monde c'est à nous de faire en sorte que
ce soit pas la fin du monde et en fait
il y a des trajectoires il y a de la
planification donc c'est à nous
responsable politique de montrer qu'il y
a des solutions ça c'est le le premier
point le deuxième point c'est que ces
solutions faut la mettre à la portée de
toutes les bourses l'écologie ne peut
pas être un bien de luxe donc pour
mettre ces solutions à la portée de
toutes les bourses c'est ce que nous
faisons par exemple sur la voiture
électrique la voiture électrique avec le
leasing à 100 € par mois ou avec les
aides qui vont être renforcé prime
laacasse bonus écologique et les aides
complémentaires pour euh les les
citoyens qui sont le prê àau Z0 les
citoyens qui sont concernés par les
zones à faible émission vous pouvez
arriver jusqu'à 15000 € aujourd'hui et
là aussi avec des voitures qui par
ailleurs arrivent à 25000 € sur le
marché sur vous vous arrivez à mettre la
voiture neuve aux alentours de 10 12000
€ et demain vous créez un marché de la
voiture d'occasion puisque dans 3 4 ans
c'estes voitures reviendront sur le
marché d'occasion et vous entraînez une
dynamique où là ça devient vient un
marché qui commence à être accessible et
qui le sera progressivement et qui
devient une solution pour les Français
avec aussi cet objectif de développer
plus de petits modèles qui soient des
modèles aussi plus accessibles plus
compétitifs en prix donc ça c'est c'est
un des enjeux on peut retrouver la la
même chos sur la rénovation thermique
donc mettre l'écologie à la portée de de
toutes les bourses et accompagner ceux
qui sont aujourd'hui dans des situations
où ils subissent la le dérèglement
climatique ils n'ont pas les solutions à
apporter c'est hab moin de mon travail
j'ai pas les moyens de changer de
voiture je suis dans une passeoire
thermique et ça et donc là on doit avoir
une réponse politique puis la deuxième
chose c'est qu' il faut des bénéfices
égoïstes à la transition énergétique et
moi les meilleurs bénéfices égoïstes que
j'ai trouver la transition énergétique
ils sont de trois ordres il y a le
pouvoir d'achat lorsqu'on met les
solutions à
apporter si je vous fais passer à la
voiture électrique alors derrière sur le
carburant vous
gagnez 1200 € par an pour le trajet
moyen que font les Français 12000 km
donc là ça commence à se
voir je peux le dire aussi sur le gaz
versus électricité vous avez un bénéfice
à basculer à l'électricité alors c'est
pas pas possible par partout et cetera
mais il y a un bénéfice c'est mesuré
c'est étayé deuxième bénéfice c'est un
bénéfice santé et ça ça passe plus par
les les solutions de renaturation autour
de la biodiversité de lutte contre la
pollution de l'air donc il faut associer
la baisse des émissions de CO2 à
d'autres types de lutte le la si moi je
vous raconte que les Z les zones à
faible émission ça divise par de c'est
pas un
chiffre d'expert c'est c'est un propos
générique pour fixer les idées ça divise
par de le nombre d'enfants qui ont des
bronchiolit et le nombre d'enfants qu'on
de l'ASME dans les zones concernées je
pense que ça parlera nettement plus aux
gens et le nombre de TC précoce et là on
doit vraiment faire un travail pour
mettre ces ces objectifs en relation et
la troisème chose c'est l'amélioration
du cadre de vie si je vous dis que la
réduction de la pollution lumineuse
c'est en quelques mois pas en quelques
années et à l'autre bout de la terre
c'est en quelques mois une évolution
massive sur la qualité de la
biodiversité locale les insectes les
oiseaux et cetera c'est peut-être
quelque chose qui parle qui parlera au
au français en tout état de cause il
faut que nos politiques écologique et
des retombées
locales et immédiates pour les gens qui
sont concernés le dernier le dernier
pilier c'est la réindustrialisation et
les emplois c'est-à-dire que quitte à
mettre beaucoup d'argent dans la
rénovation thermique dans la voiture
électrique et dans toutes les solutions
de décarbonation il faut qu'à la fin le
maximum retombe sur le territoire
français avec à la clé des emplois des
entreprises qui développent de la
richesse pour les territoires des
ressources fiscales pour les budgets qui
soient locaux ou nationaux des charges
sociales qui permettent de financer
notre système de sécurité sociale je
pense pense que c'est vraiment les trois
conditions qui qui fonctionnent et on a
encore un travail à faire
pour mettre ensemble et notamment le
sujet de la la santé qui peut-être
encore en mode mineur alors que ça va
être un sujet majeur dans les années qui
viennent le covid étant peut-être un
acousqui de qui nous attend derrière
voilà sur la question
de du fond perte et préjudice je pense
que c'est à ça que vous faisiez
référence donc comme je l'ai indiqué
dans mon propos introductif euh ça a été
un des enjeux sur lequel on
euh on s'est réuni pendant la la
précop27 et notamment la France et le
bangladesch ont été missionnés pour
essayer de trouver un élan et de pousser
politiquement le sujet la dernière
négociation du groupe transactionnel a
trouvver un accord cet accord nous nous
convient et il a été arraché au forceps
mais avec euh la forte détermination euh
de la présidence je pense que c'est un
indice intéressant en tout cas de son
implication et de sa volonté de faire
aboutir les sujets et cet accord
prévient bien la qu'il a un fond que ce
fond soit financé pas seulement par les
pays développés et qu'il soit bien
dirigé en priorité vers les pays les
plus vulnérables qui étaient vraiment
les les trois sujets qui pour nous
étaient importants
euh sur
euh la comment créer d'autres source de
financement
d'investissement beaucoup de de
réflexion
euh la fiscalité carbone en Europe vous
savez que de ce point de vue-là il y a
dans fed for 55 un certain nombre
d'éléments qui sont qui sont pris en
compte avec d'un côté une augmentation
du champ d'action enfin du champ
d'application de la fiscalité carbone et
de l'autre côté un fond social pour le
climat qui permet de
euh équilibrer les choses et de
justement répondre à à l'objectif de
transition juste c'est-à-dire d'amortir
l'impact sur les ménages et de faire en
sorte que ce soit en particulier les les
entreprises et les les autres acteurs
qui soient concernés par par cette
taxation carbone qui est progressive
deuxièmement quelles sont les sources
d'autres flux le président de la
République et et et et et d'autres ont
porté l'idée de taxes qui puissent être
internationale on pense évidemment au
secteur de l'aviation ça fera écho aussi
à certaines questions que vous avez eu
monsieur le sénateur sur le transport
maritime qui est une autre piste
sur
éventuellement secteur de l'énergie là
c'est un peu plus incertain les les deux
pistes les plus concrètes sont plutôt
les deux que je viens de de mentionner
euh et puis il y a ensuite comment on
fait venir du financement privé en
dérisquant les projets je pense que et
comment on fait levier sur les grandes
institutions la finance en les les
banques de développement multilatéral le
FMI et la Banque mondiale pour changer
les modalités de règles du jeu parce
qu'elles ont vieilli on n plus du temps
de Breton Woods on est dans un autre
dans un autre moment où les
problématiques sont différentes il est
très difficile par exemple de dire bah
on peut pas vous apporter un soutien
vous avez un événement climatique majeur
parce que votre niveau de dette
international bloque les financements et
donc vous vous débrouillez au milieu de
votre inondation majeure qui est en
train de mettre par terre votre économie
donc là c'est à la fois l'enjeu de perte
et judice mais c'est également l'enjeu
plus largement d'avoir une finance où la
le développement soit le le une phase de
la pièce de la financement de la finance
climat et c'est tout ce qui a été listé
comme élément pour améliorer la finance
climat dans le cadre de de l'accord
enfin du du sommet de Paris que nous
avons que le Président de la République
dont le président de la République a eu
l'initiative sur la stratégie européenne
il y en a une elle a fait l'objet d'un
d'un mandat vous savez que que à la COP
c'est l'Union européenne qui négocie
avec ensuite les ministres qui se déploi
pour faire bouger les lignes mais autour
d'un mandat unique et ce mandat unique
il a été adopté à l'unanimité lors du
conseil de l'environnement le 16 octobre
dernier et il a plutôt un langage un
langage qui est ambitieux d'ailleurs il
reprend nous les les objectifs que nous
avions c'est-à-dire il évoque le
triplement des énergies renouvelables le
doublement de l'efficacité énergétique
euh la question de euh alors la
rédaction sur la sortie des énergies
fossiles elle est subtile comme
d'habitude mais elle y est euh oui elle
est subtile mais enfin c'est c'est bien
ça il y a pas de date voilà c'est ça il
y a bien la sortie des énergies fossiles
mais il y a un flou sur la date c'est
déjà assez important qu'on ait obtenu ça
à l'unanimité euh on a une mention aux
énergies aux économies d'énergie donc à
la sobriété on a une mention
un système à toutes les autres sources
qui permettent d'avoir un système
énergétique propre donc en gros le
nucléaire donc on a à peu près nos nos
petits qui sont qui sont en place dans
dans ce mandat et si vous êtes intéressé
on peut vous le communiquer parce qu'il
est assez je dirais en lecture directe
sur le méthane c'est ce que je je
j'indiquis on a à la fois une coalition
qui va euh demander des engagements aux
pétroliers et gaziers pour la réduction
de leur émission de CO2 sur leurs
opération et donc l'interdiction du
torchage la les investissements pour
limiter les fuites de méthane et ça
c'est un objet de du premier jour de la
COP 28 sous la forme d'une coalition et
nous à titre européen nous portons un
règlement métal qui est plus ambitieux
et qui prévoit effectivement le euh des
objectifs de de réduction de l'impact
méthane dans nos opérations et dans les
importations ce qui est essentiel
puisque c'est ça qui va faire qui va
déclencher aussi ses investissements
chez nos fournisseurs c'est d'ailleurs
et c'est pas complètement neutre assez
soutenu par les Américains qui je pense
ont l'intention de beaucoup investir sur
ce cet objet là et de créer une forme de
d'avantage compétitif donc euh voilà
manifestement les les ONG retrouvent
l'économie de marché je ne sais pas non
c'est pas très bien ce que je
euh sur la question de l'assèchement des
financements pour les fossiles ben c'est
la démarche que j'ai mentionné hein sur
les banques c'est-à-dire 2030 2040
comment on peut aller plus loin pour
avoir des objectifs plus courts
spécifiquement sur le charbon par type
aussi de financement entre le
financement de projets dédiés le
financement d'une entreprise qui fait du
charbon mais pas que surtout beaucoup
d'entreprises peuvent se prévaloir de
faire et des énergies renouvelable et du
fossile donc comment on arrive à mettre
les banques les assureurs enfin toutes
en fait les fond d'investissement autour
de la table pour avoir des règles du jeu
qui resserrent encore sur le charbon les
les engagements et les obligation sur
l'hydrogène blanc je laisserai le
spécialiste en parler non si si mais non
je moi je peux vous le dire sur la
vision gouvernementale mais je suis pas
l'experte non je suis pas non c'est
c'est l'hydrogène natif c'est bien mais
par que est-ce que est-ce que je sais
pas quel est le potentiel dans dans la
donc j'ai pas l'idée du potentiel donc
sur l'hydrogène blanc la position en
fait elle est triple c'est un oui c'est
de l'hydrogène et sous ce registr là ce
n'est pas émetteur de de carbone de le
potentiel aujourd'hui n'est pas
complètement connu et plutôt estimé
comme étant intéressant mais pas
nécessairement de nature à changer les
équation générale mais enfin c'est pas
parce que c'est ça ne change pas
l'équation générale qu'il faut pas
regarder donc nous on a on instruit des
permis d'exploration et des permis
d'exploitation et trois points centrals
en revanche c'est qu'il faudrait pas que
le processus d'exploitation donne lieu à
du dégagement de
méthane et comme ça se trouve souvent
dans des milieux miniers puisque c'est
là où les problèmes peuvent
survenir c'est que effectivement à la
faveur de la recherche hydrogène blanc
vous libériez du méthane dont on a vu
qu'il était très problématique dans le
réchauffement
climatique sur les énergies
renouvelables l'intérêt de la loi
d'accélération énergie renouvelable
c'est précisément qu'elle donne des
pouvoirs de planification aux élus
locaux c'est qu'elle permet sur
l'agricovoltaïsme d'avoir un
avis enfin d'avoir
une des avis de la CdP NAF qui qui sont
conformes c'est-à-dire que en fait tout
le
développement de des énergies
renouvelables aujourd'hui est remis au
niveau territorial dans le cadre d'un
pacte territorial avec les élus locaux
et leur donne des éléments pour orienter
et accompagner de manière bien plus
harmonieuse le développement des
énergies renouvelables sur leur
territoire je crois que c'est le grand
acquis de de cette loi la contrepartie
c'est qu'il faut jouer le jeu
c'est-à-dire si vous ne vous engagez pas
dans une planification énergétique si
vous ne donnez pas des zones
d'accélération et bien alors il n'y aura
pas de zone d'interdiction et bien alors
on limite les développements sur le
sujet de
l'agrivoltaïsme je veux redire que ce
dont on parle he c'est un milliè de pour
de enfin c'est 1 milliè pardon de notre
zone agricole utile donc on n'est pas
sur des développements en terme de de
besoin on n'est pas sur des
développements
important là où il faut faire attention
c'est effectivement d'éviter la loi est
très bien écrite é la loi il dit tout ce
qu'il faut qu'il ait dans la loi la
difficulté c'est qu'elle soit bien
appliquée je pense que c'est comme vous
disiez la méthanisation c'est vrai que
la méthanisation les contournements
existent on va pas se mettre les mains
devant les yeux donc le sujet c'est
qu'elle soit bien appliquée pour qu'elle
soit bien
appliquer notre objectif c'est
effectivement d'avoir un travail étroit
avec les
organisations agricoles qui a été entamé
au niveau de Marc Phen et de moi-même on
a un projet de décret mais sur lequel on
a vraiment travaillé et on on n pas le
sentiment d'y être totalement on est
assez précautionneux sur ce sujet-là il
semblerait que il y ait des sujets qui
sont les cultures par exemple la
viticulture l'arboriculture où il y a
des cas qui sont bien établis sur lequel
la prise de risque est modérée
c'est-à-dire on va pas avoir un
changement du jour au lendemain de
l'exploitation dans une autre direction
pour faire semblant de faire de
l'agriculture de l'élevage et puis
mettre au-dessus des des panneaux qui
sont l'objet principal de l'exploitation
euh sur les grandes cultures et sur
l'élevage il y a une dimension de de
précaution supplémentair qu'il faut
avoir et on continuer à y travailler
avec le ministre de l'agriculture
notamment sur la répartition de la
valeur qui est le point clé du du sujet
entre le propriétaire l'exploitant et
l'opérateur sur sur l'aérien alors ce
n'est pas nous qui décidons de ne pas
prendre les émissions de CO2 des
transports aériens internationaux c'est
la convention internation
qui le prévoit en revanche il y a bien
un travail au niveau européen
typiquement sur la trajectoire de
décarbonation de l'aviation en général
notamment avec le règlement refuel
aviation aviation qui avec un mauvais
accent qui prévoit une incorporation
progressive de biocarburant
dans ce qui ce qui est les soutes
européennes donc c'est une première
réponse à la question vous savez qu'au
niveau français par ailleurs nous avons
augmenté les taxes très de manière très
importante notamment sur le kérosè qui
est utilisé dans les
jets 80 % aujourd'hui he en 2 ans 23 et
24 et
donc la la l'orientation que nous avons
c'est une diminution du nombre de vols
enfin de l'utilisation de l'avion sur
des trajets qui ont une
alternative sur un un temps de de
déplacement qui est
je dirais acceptable en tout cas alors
c'est 3h on l'a dans les référentiels de
de l'État dans les références enfin en
gros un fonctionnaire aujourd'hui n'a
pas le droit de prendre l'avion si il a
une alternative par train de moins de 3
He
euh on se l'applique nous-même en tant
que enfin en tout cas moi je me
l'applique moi-même en tant que ministre
sauf cas très extrême mais sinon on est
bien sur sur ça et euh c'est déployé
dans beaucoup d'entreprises du CAC 40 on
est en train trînne de l'élargir aux
entreprises du
SBF 120 donc ça c'est la partie sobriété
et sur la
partie sur la partie normative on a tout
un travail qui est mené aussi on l'a vu
sur les vols intérieurs ce qui est
directement dans notre main et de
négociation au niveau européen et au
niveau
international siété
euh la sobriété
elle n'est pas contrainte les résultats
que nous avons on eu sur la sobriété on
les retrouve dans les entreprises du 440
au niveau des administrations centrales
au niveau des administrations des
concentré au niveau des collectivité
territorial et on a des suivis qui sont
assez précis notamment sur les bâtiments
donc en tout état de cause ce n'est pas
le résidentiel qui porte la la baisse
enin je veux dire c'est partagé par tout
le monde et assez largement ça c'est
vraiment le premier point et d'ailleurs
on le voit très nettement sur l'année
dernière alors que le prix de
l'électricité du G gaz est stable sur
l'année en tout cas entre le 1er février
et la fin d'année on voit très
clairement le décrocher à partir du mois
d'octobre de la consommation
d'énergie che dans le résidentiel donc
c'est vous le voyez dans le tertiaire
vous le voyez dans la grande
distribution c'est un sujet qui a été
très largement pris en main sérieusement
dans le cadre du Plan sobriété je
rappelle que le plan sobriété c'est 300
fédérations qui s'engagent toutes les
entreprises du CAC 40 10 secteurs
d'activité donc on est c'est pas juste
j'ai réglé mon chauffage à la maison où
j'ai pas les moyens de le monter je veux
le dire parce que je trouve que c'est
intéressant de voir l'impact que ça a eu
et d'ailleurs on le voit l'été
c'està-dire que on continue à baisser
notre consommation d'électricité et de
gaz au moment où les Français n'ont pas
besoin de se chauffer ce qui montre bien
que ce plan est allé bien au-delà de la
seule question du chauffage chez les
personnes en situation de précarité et
dans le même mouvement nous avons
renforcé les moyens d'aide aux personnes
en situation de précarité pour leur
permettre de se chauffer à un niveau
acceptable la sobriété c'est 19°gr pour
tout le monde c'est pas 14°grés chez les
un et 23°grés chez les autres ça c'est
inacceptable donc il y en a qui montent
il y en a qui descendent et et et c'est
la vision de transition juste que nous
portons et en plus il se trouve que le
corps médical Michel Simes pour ne pas
le citer vous expliquera très bien
pourquoi en plus c'est très bon pour la
santé donc ça tombe bien voilà donc je
je pense que il faut être assez clair
sur ça euh les crédits noveaux oui c'est
des crédits noveaux ça il y a pas de
doute sur le fait que c'est des crédits
nveaux euh les marges de manœuvre des
collectivités locales il me semble qu'il
y a un bon rapport de la Cour des
comptes sur les marges de manœuvre des
collectivités locales je me permet de
renvoyer vers ce rapport qui a l'air de
dire qu'il y en a quand même quelquesun
après je ne suis pas une spécialiste des
finances
locales mais je je ne me permettrai pas
de critiquer la Cour des comptes et sur
euh la question du nucléaire pardon mais
c'est une énergie d'autonomie
nous avons une indépendance sur le
nucléaire à 95 % je peux pas en dire
autant du solaire je ne suis pas
dépendant indépendante à 95 % sur la
filière solaire je ne suis pas
indépendante à 95 % sur la
filiière sur la filière éolienne
terrestre je ne suis pas plus sur la
filière
éolienne
offshore j'ai des niveaux de dépendance
qui sont diversifiés 85 % des panneaux
photovoltaïques qui sont en produit en
dehors d'Europe une partie des méth
critiques pour notre transition
énergétique et notamment qui sont en
appui des énergies renouvelabl sont
produits en dehors d'Europe et sont
raffinés en dehors d'Europe donc nous
avons des politiques pour augmenter
notre niveau de souveraineté sur ces
différentes filières on a un Pact éolien
la la commissaire européenne a annoncé
un Pact unact solaire pardon la
commissaire européen a annoncé un Pact
éolien on travaille sur le critical raw
material Act tous ces sujets sont
adressés mais aujourd'hui la vérité
commande de dire que la filière dans
lequelle on a le niveau d'indépendance
le plus élevé c'est la filière nucléaire
je suis désolé d'être factuelle mais
c'est la réalité y compris sur l'uranium
naturel parce que sincèrement c'est plus
facile de se sourcer dans des pays qui
en produisent ou qui en ont comme
l'Australie ou le
Canada que d'aller chercher du cobalt du
nckel et du lithium raffiné qui est
essentiellement en Chine parce que il
suffit pas d'avoir des terres encore
faut-il le raffiner au gradient batterie
électrique et ça on l'a pas en Europe on
l'a pas on est en train de le construire
mais on l'a pas
aujourd'hui non c'est c'est là aussi
c'est c'est vraiment le truc sur le
cycle d'uranium on n pas besoin des
Russes la seule partie sur lequelle on a
besoin des Russes ou qui est un qui
n'est pas un point bloquant qui est un
point où on a un contrat de retraitement
on peut faire sans retraitement on n pas
besoin de de retraiter c'est mieux de
retraiter pour des raisons de gestion
des des des déchets mais on n pas besoin
si demain le contrat s'arrête euh nos
centrales ne s'arrêtent pas ça se
poursuit et on a même la maîtrise de la
technologie donc en fait non alors que
moi on est bien d'accord que l'uranium
est importé quand même je viens de le
dire sur l'uranium naturel je dis que
j'ai pas beaucoup de sourcing sur des
matières premières critiques sur la
transition énergétique que je peux
sourcer en Australie et au Canada il en
a pas beaucoup bah écoutez il y a des
articles j'en ai encore un sous les yeux
qui dit c'est un tour de passe-pe en
fait la réalité c'est qu'on importe la
total non mais si vous préférez si vous
pensez que la réalité des médias est
d'un niveau de de de sécurité sur
l'information meilleur que ce que je
peux vous dire je je vous en laisse
l'appréciation moi je vous dis ce qui
est la réalité nous avons un
multisourcing sur l'uranium naturel nous
avons des stocks nous avons la capacité
à comment dire enrichir à mettre en en
format de de de crayon pour apporter
dans les centrales nucléaires et nous
avons la la capacité de gestion avale il
y a pas beaucoup de pays qui peuvent
s'en prévaloir même pas les États-Unis
même pas les États-Unis et donc vous
maintenez que sur l'uranium pour vous il
y a pas d'importation je dis pas qu'il y
a pas d'importation je dis qu'on n pas
dépendant j'ai dit très exactement le
contraire je dis qu'on est pas dépendant
et ce qui est quand même très important
bah si parce que pour le coup sur le
photovoltaïque faites un projet
photovoltaïque sans les
Chinois faites un projet d'éolien
terrestre en fait un projet d'éolien
mais oui donc oui il y a plusieurs
années qu'on aura déjà d monsieur le
Président je je me permets
d'intervenir l'objectif de cette réunion
c'était une audition de Madame la
Ministre et Monsieur jusel pour savoir
quelle était la position de la France en
vue de la
COP intéressant on a plein de débat
intéressant pourra y passer des heures
et moi je souhaiterais plutôt plôt que
qu'on entende madame la ministre
jusqu'au bout et je demande aux
collègues s'ils ont des questions
particulières de les poser par écrit ou
dans un autre cadre mais je rappelle
simplement le le cadre de cette audition
c'était bien c'était bien une table
ronde sur la préparation de la COP 28 et
en plus il y a le temps il faut qu'on se
voit à faut qu'on parte à 19h à je
m'excuse mais il y a la CMP Serme il
faut qu'on parte à 19 non 19h30 c'est
c'est 19h30 il faut qu'on parte à 19h et
puis mais qu'on en parle un petit peu
avant avec vous pour ne pas que on
arrive en désordre et sur sur les
hydroliennes je je je vous le dis moi je
me suis battu pour que le projet flowat
est un tarif de rachat c'est un projet
qui a une capacité de développement
industrielle la situation de est un
petit peu différente et je rentrerai pas
dans dans les détails mais oui la
filière hydrolienne elle est elle est
également soutenue elle est soutenue
dans le cadre d'un de de projets qu'on
que l'on porte avec un tarif de rachat
Monsieur
jusel Merci non moi je veux pas faire de
mauvais esprit non plus mais il y a deux
types d'indépendance c'estàd il y a
l'indépendance dans la construction d'
infrastructure et là vous avez raison
mais disons réellement indépendant une
fois que les infrastructures sont
construites c'est quand même bien le
renouvelable vous avez besoin de une
fois que les c'est bien ça problème
c'est que tous les 20 ans non mais on
est d'accord mais il faut bien il faut
bien faire la part pour moi il d'accord
il y a deux types d'indépendance bon
voilà mais je vais pas je vais pas vous
prendre beaucoup de temps non parce
qu'il y a beaucoup de questions qui ont
été qui ont été redites bon simplement
peut-être des petites des des petites
réaction sur sur quelques en des
commentaires très
rapides moi moi il y a toujours la
question que que Renant a soulevé qui
qui me qui me qui m'interroge
l'additivité c'estàd tu tu as parlé de
l'adtivité Renant à l'échelle
planétaire bon quand même force de
constater qu'en France on a fait
beaucoup de transport en commun on a
fait un plan vélo on fait du covoiturage
euh on fait des voitures électriques on
commence et puis malgré tout ça le
thermique continue à augmenter ENF en
proportion peut-être pas en absolu mais
enfin disons il diminue pas beaucoup
hein donc c'est quand même la question
comment comment on fait ça pour le
transport c'est quand même bien la
question parce qu'on fait de
l'additivité actuellement bon ça c'est
une première enfin je pense que c'est
important d'avoir bien ça en tête si
vous regardez les chiffres des émissions
liées au transport c'estd le thermique
bon il diminue pas vraiment alors en
proportion certainement pas mais bon
voilà donc en en fait lativité c'est
c'est la question qu'on doit se poser
dans l'organisation de nos sociétés
voilà
donc oui bah oui c'est parce que bien
sûr on sait très bien pourquoi la
population augmente le nombre de
kilomètres par personne augmente ça on
est d'accord he donc mais voilà mais on
peut se poser les questions quand même
comment on fait c'est ça je suis
d'accord avec l'analyse il y a pas de
problème c'est simple donc bon moi je je
vais répéter les choses que vous avez
dites madame la ministre mais bon bon
c'est vrai que que comment on fait pour
bon comment on fait pour essayer de
faire adhérer c'est c'est quand même
bien ça donc comment on fait bon moi moi
j'aime bien j'aime quand même bien dire
que bon le pétrole alors c'est movais
pour le gaz mais le pétrole et le
charbon quand même à part nous fournir
l'énergie c'est quand même bien des
sources de pollution les premières
disons pollution urbaine pollution
industrielle voilà pollution automobile
mais aussi pollution sonore donc si on
s'en passe ça fait beaucoup de bien vous
l'avez dit je vous bon voilà c'est très
clair encore peut-être les gaz c'est
moin enfin bon voilà je veux pas donc
mais il faut quand même bien comprendre
que c'est un argument très fort sur la
santé et sur la simple pollution même la
pollution sonore c'est aussi quelque
foois des problèmes de santé hein voilà
moi mais moi j'aime bien j'aime bien
dire c'est vrai que que bon c'est quand
même le dynamisme économique la qualité
de vie vous l'avez dit mais c'est quand
même le dynamisme économique alors ça
commence à venir disons les enfin ENF il
se fait que c'est des petits enfants bon
voilà il voit bien que c'est là où ça
bouge quand même il faut Pasin disons
bon ce dynamisme économique il faut le
construire autour de la transition he je
je je enfin voilà je redis que cette
transition il faut la faire il faut la
la la
réussir et il y va du dynamisme
économique alors je sais bien que le
court terme c'est difficile mais à moyen
terme j'en suis convaincu donc bon
simplement pour dire que moi aussi vous
l'avez dit moi j'ai regardé un peu la il
a oui il y a une stratégie européenne
qui est ambitieuse et qui est ouverte
voilà donc
on va pas dire donc on va voir comment
l'Europe va va conduire les négociations
mais bon on peut pas dire qu'il y a pas
de stratégie européenne elle est quand
même enfin moi je regardé des analyses
de la stratégie européenne on peut pas
dire qu'elle soit pas ambitieuse alors
bon pas suffisamment par rapport à ce
qui nous réunit aujourd'hui quand même
il y a trois étapes qu'il faut bien
regarder accepter l'idée qu'il faut
arrêter qu'il faut un jour arrêter le
fauxile alors si on donne pas de date
c'est pas terrible ça serait mieux de
donner une date et ensuite quandme même
la 3oisème étape ça serait de dire quand
même un vrai moratoire voilà c'est je
reviens à
notre voilà c'est c'est quand même ça la
véritable ambition donc la véritable
ambition ce serait de déjà de donner une
date à la fin du fossile parce que je
vois pas comment on peut mettre 2050
pour 1 degré 5 et pas donner de date à
la fin du fossile ça bon je veux dire ça
ça marche pas c'est on le sait très bien
voilà donc moi c'est un encouragement
j'ai bon je serai aussi à la COP une
partie euh voilà donc j'ai j'ai ça va
être ma 20e j'ai fait toutes les copes
depuis 2001
je pense que ça sert à quelque chose
voilà j'espère simplement que que
celle-ci vous servira aussi un peu même
je suis moins pessimiste aussi certains
autres sur le fait que ça se passe
disons à Dubaï bon moi je je pense aussi
qu' on peut pas discuter de la fin du
pétrole sans les pétroliers donc c'est
très clair je l'ai dit d'ailleurs de
façon assez claire voilà moi je voudrais
vous remercier voilà mais merci mais
quand même soyez ambitieuse hein
c'est l'ambition c'est le moratoire
allez donc merci beaucoup pour moi
merci donc voilà dans l'hydrogène
j'aurais un peu dit ce que j'ai pas mais
vous avez une idée sur le potentiel non
justement il faudrait que je regarde je
peux regarder mais moi justement j'ai
j'ai l'idée qu'il y a pas d'idée sur le
potentiel ça ça veut dire justement
qu'il faut aller mais plutôt je serais
plutôt encouragé à aller voir quand même
ce potentiel faut essayer de le regarder
donc monsieur monsieur monsieur jusel
peut-être juste pour réagir vraiment en
un mot c'est que quand même le BRGM a
sorti une étude pour dire que en
l'occurrence la ressource en hydrogène
en plus il son régénéré était était
énorme enfin c'est c'est quand même il y
a eu des études sur le sujet
semblerait-il des articles de pre qu'il
l'ont redit donc c'est pour ça que il y
a en voilà c'est quand même un sujet
dont il faudrait au moins se saisir ouis
voilà euh pardon je vais être très clair
on s'en est saisi puisqu'on a des on est
en train de regarder des permis
d'exploration donc je c'est une manière
je connais pas plus concret pour s'en
saisir après il faut pas que ce soit
l'occasion de sortir du méthane de terre
c'est donc voilà c'est très très clair
je je tiens je tiens vraiment à
remercier Madame la Ministre et Monsieur
jusel d'avoir accepté de participer et à
cette table ronde préparatoire à la à la
COP 28 je vous remercie pour pour pour
vos réponses je vous remercie pour pour
l'ambition qu'on a et vous avez que vous
défendrez à cette COP 28 et pour
conclure je reprendrai simplement une
interview de
jean-josel qui a qui disait dans cette
interview la seule façon d'aller de
l'avant c'est d'agir et je pense qu'il
faut que toutes et tous au-delà de de ce
qu'on peut penser de retrouver des
choses de se dire oui mais j'ai entendu
j'ai de polémiquer de euh de faire un
tas de chose je pense que effectivement
il faut qu'on agisse euh moi je
reprendrai bien ce qu' ditv gilet parce
que c'est vrai qu'on se dit oui mais
nous on est qu'à 1 % donc c'est pas très
grave c'est bien nous nous cassons pas
la tête par rapport aux autres qui sont
à 15 % 20 % je sais pas quoi euh je
pense que effectivement votre phrase est
très bonne c'est allons de l'avant et
agiss
mais agissons tous
ensem merci
oui mais c'est parce que on doit se voir
avec celles et ceux qui viennent à
la